bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat à suivre ce
matin les auditions organisées par la
commission des Finances ainsi que celle
des affaires sociales du Sénat de deux
futurs membres du hautceil des finances
cette instance qui s'assurera du respect
de la règle d'or budgétaire c'est-à-dire
celle qui oblige la France à équilibrer
ses dépenses et ses recettes pour
atteindre un budget à l'équilibre en
2017 il s'agit de l'économiste Michel
Aglietta et de l'actuelle directrice des
études économiques de HSBC France
Mathilde leemoine c'est Jean-Pierre
belle le président du Sénat qui a nommé
le premier quant à la seconde elle a été
choisie par le président de la
commission des finances du Sénat
Philippe Marini ceut conseil qui est
composé de 10 membres cinq femmes et 5q
hommes sera présidé par Didier Migot le
premier président de la Cour des comptes
il doit entrer en fonction ce mois-ci
mais tout de suite direction la salle
micis pour les auditions de Mathilde le
mooine et de Michel Agliata les deux
futurs membres du Haut Conseil des
finances très bonne matinée à tous sur
Public Sénat madame la Présidente de la
Commission des Affaires
social messieurs les rapporteurs
généraux mes chers collègues nous sommes
réunis en salle mdicis ce matin pour un
exercice d'un type nouveau puisqu'il
s'agit de deux auditions
successives préalable à des
nomination mais qui sont des auditions
qui ne se concluront pas par des votes
ce sont des auditions que je qualifierai
d'auditions de
transparence puisque le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques est une nouvelle
instance de notre République et que
parmi ces membres figurent des
personnalités issues de la désignation
des autorités
parlementaires président du Sénat
président de l'Assemblée nationale
président des commissions des finances
de chaque assemblée et si on assimile ce
qui à mon avis est exccess
le Conseil économique et social a une
autorité paraparlementaire ou quasi
parlementaire effectivement il y a une
désignation d'ailleurs de l'un de vos
collègues économistes à ce titre et donc
monsieur le Président du Sénat a
pressenti pour ce Haut Conseil des
finances publiques le professeur Michel
agli éat et qui est ici parmi nous et eu
qui va euh se présenter et répondre à
quelques questions
et après que je vous ai rappelé en
quelques mot et que euh la loi organique
relative à la programmation et à la
gouvernance des finances publiques a
pour objet de transposer dans notre
droit national certaines des nouvelles
règles de gouvernance budgétaire
élaborées au niveau européen nous avons
donc pour la première fois dans notre
ordre juridique un haut conseil qui va
devoir veiller à la bonne application
des règles de gouvernance
budgétaire qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
le Haut Conseil devra
collégialement vérifier si notre
trajectoire de solde structurel est bien
respectée
cette expression est apparemment simple
derrière cette expression se réfugie des
notion intellectuelle complexe et il
faut certainement des personnalités
comme le professeur
Aglietta pour nous faire croire que nous
sommes plus intelligents que nous ne le
sommes en général il y parvient fort
bien et pour nous dire les enjeux qui
figurent derrière ce mot structurel
et qu'est-ce qui est structurel
qu'est-ce qui est conjoncturel où passe
la limite qui définit cette limite qui
définit le cycle économique et l'espace
de temps dans lequel il
s'inscrit cette définition doit-elle
être la même pour tous les États de la
zone euro le Haut conseil c'est un
organisme indépendant qui devra donner
un avis sur les prévisions
macro-économiques taux de
croissance parité
monétaire solde extérieur sur lesquels
sont fondés les textes financiers et le
Sénat a tenu à ce que cet avis s'exprime
aussi bien sur les lois de finance
rectificativ que sur les lois
financières initiales loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale ou loi de
finances de l'État donner un avis un
avis cela peut-être tout cela peut-être
rien alors où se situera le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques comment fera-t-il
collégialement évoluer sa pratique et
donc sa jurisprudence vous le savez mes
chers collègues nous avons exclus dans
le texte les opinions dissidentes et un
membre du Haut Conseil ne pourra pas
s'exprimer à titre individuel mais c'est
bien le Haut Conseil collégialement qui
fera prévaloir son approche donc le
professeur Aglietta nous éclairera sans
doute sur la manière
dont il perçoit il
comprend le cadre dans lequel
s'inscrivent les responsabilités du Haut
Conseil
et nous allons ce matin entendre
successivement le professeur Aglietta
pressenti par le président du Sénat et
selon les vertu de la parité et il m'est
revenu de pressentir une dame madame
mathil Le Moine alors le tirage au sort
qui a été effectué devant témoin par le
premier président de la Cour des comptes
Didier Migot président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques a été plein de
révérence puisque si j'ose ainsi
m'exprimer ne le prenez pas en mauvaise
part les présidents des assemblées ont
tiré les hommes et les présidents des
commissions des Finances ont tiré les
dames et donc nous allons entendre
successivement Michel Aglietta puis
Mathilde Lemoine nous nous efforcerons
de leur poser les mêmes questions étant
rappeler que l'article 11 de la loi
organique dispose que les personnes
choisies doivent
disposer de
compétences dans le domaine des
prévisions macroéconomiques et des
finances publiques bon les compétences
je crois nous avons lu la liste des
personnalités pressent
me semble à titre personnel qu' ne peut
pas y avoir de doute sur les compétences
mais le texte dispose également que dans
l'exercice de leur mission les membres
du Haut Conseil ne peuvent solliciter ou
recevoir aucune instruction du
gouvernement ou de toute autre personne
publique ou privée donc les membres du
Haut Conseil doivent résoudre une
quadrature du cercle ils doivent être
totalement compétents et parfaitement
indépendants
alors il appartiendra donc à Monsieur
Aglietta puis à Madame le moine de nous
convaincre de leur
indépendance d'esprit et de jugement
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales va à présent
s'exprimer puis nous entendrons monsieur
Aglietta dans un exposé liminaire au
cours duquel sans doute abordera-t-il
les quelques questions de fond que j'ai
évoqué et puis euh les rapporteurs
généraux
questionneront le le le le comment dire
vous n'êtes pas candidat vous n'avez été
candidat à rien mais le haut conseiller
pressenti on va vous appeler comme ça
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a mis seul sur
l'estrade c'est parce que c'est un haut
conseil voilà donc les rapporteurs
généraux vous questionneront vous leur
répondrez et ensuite les membres de de
nos deux commissions des affaires
sociales et des Finances merci de votre
attention madame la Présidente je vous
en prie merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les rapporteurs généraux
monsieur le professeur mes chers
collègues je vais pas être longue le
président Marini a a dit d'essentiel je
voulais simplement insister sur
l'originalité de de de la situation et
le fait que nous soyons de manière assez
inhabituel commission des finances et
commission des affaires
sociales rassembl pour cette audition
puisqueen effet le président Marini
vient de le rappeler c'est donc la loi
organique du 17 décembre dernier qui a
prévu cette procédure d'audition par nos
deux commissions il s'agit finalement
d'une conséquence logique de la
compétence financière qui a été
maintenant reconnu à la commission des
affaires sociales et ceci depuis
1996 et l'instauration des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale au
cours des débats sur la loi organique
notre rapportte ur général d'ailleurs
Yve dodini a insisté sur la nécessité de
bien intégrer la dimension finances
social dans l'ensemble des dispositifs
de programmation et de gouvernance des
finances publiques y compris bien
entendu dans le rôle d'évolu au Haut
Conseil des finances public plusieurs
amendements ont d'ailleurs été adoptés
en ce sens à son
initiative cette dimension nous paraît
importante non seulement compte tenu du
poids des finances sociales dans
l'ensemble des finances publiques he je
le rappelle 50 4 % des prélèvements
obligatoires mais aussi 46 % des
dépenses mais bien sûr en raison de leur
spécificité qui doit être pleinement
prise en compte par ailleurs le
financement de la protection sociale
largement assis sur les revenus
d'activité et particulièrement sensible
aux évolutions de la conjoncture d'où
l'importance de paramètres comme le
niveau de l'emploi et des salaires il me
paraît également nécessaire de
s'interroger sur l'impact des multiples
dispositifs d'exonération de cotisation
qui ont conduit à éroder le rendement
des prélèvements sociaux et à fragiliser
de fait l'équilibre des différentes
branches c'est pourquoi vous l'aurez
compris la commission des affaires
sociales souhaite que dans ses travaux
monsieur le le professeur le Haut
conseil soit particulièrement attentif
au déterminant de l'évolution des
comptes sociaux et à leur nature
spécifique voilà je voulais simplement
insister monsieur le Président sur ces
aspects plus sociaux que nous voyons
nous au travers de cette nomination je
vous remercie
voilà Monsieur le Professeur Michel
Aglietta vous avez la
parole MAM et monsieurs les présidents
madame Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs bon je suis évidemment très
honoré de ce que le président du du
Sénat m'a choisi pour participer à cette
nouvelle
instance en fonction des directives qui
m'ont été données je parlerai d'abord de
rapidement des des compétences pour ce
type de travail ce que j'ai fait sur les
finances publiques depuis le début de la
crise ise de la zone euro et après ce
que je pense des problèmes que le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques va
rencontrer bon vous savez peut-être je
suis un universitaire r même si mon
origine est de d'être administrateur de
l'INC je suis aussi consultant au CPI à
groupe Asset
Management dans ce cadre là pour groupe
Asset Management je suis rémunéré sur
des contrats de recherche uniquement
pour ma compétence disons de d'éclairer
la macroéconomie de la de cette
entreprise je n'ai aucune appartenance
politique ni aucun intérêt financier
dans aucune société que ce soit euh en
ce qui concerne mon mon mon background
rapidement j'ai a trois choses je suis
macroéconomiste et j'ai surtout
travailler sur le long terme
c'est-à-dire associer les théories de la
croissance à l'histoire longue en
particulier je suis certaine manière un
élève de brodel et je pense que
l'histoire longue est la seule manière
de comprendre prendre la prospective
d'aborder la prospective je l'ai fait
disons sur les États-Unis dans un
travail ancien qui était ma ma thèse
dans les années 70 avec où j'ai disons
inventé d'une certaine manière ce qu'on
a appelé la théorie de la régulation
c'està-dire une analyse de la
coévolution des structures économiques
et des institutions donc faites
l'économie institutionnelle avant avant
la lettre si vous voulez puisque elle
n'a été reconnue par la théorie standard
que dans les années à partir des années
80 la la spécificité de l'étude des
institutions et j'ai appliqué ça
récemment mais vraiment tout récemment à
la Chine dans un travail très lourd que
j'ai fait avec une jeune économiste
chinoise et qui est sortie au mois de
septembre dernier ça c'est la première
dimension la deuxième c'est évidemment
monnaie et finance je travaille sur la
monnaie depuis une quarantaine d'années
euh avec une conception institutionnelle
de la monnaie la monnaie comme entité
publique bien publique et non pas du
tout la la vue réductrice qu'ont la
plupart des économistes qui identifient
la monnaie à une marchandise la monnaie
est beaucoup plus qu'une marchandise
pour ce faire j'ai codirigé deux
séminaire pluridisciplinaire à l'École
des hautes études de sciences sociales
ça a été une expérience passionnante qui
a donné lieu à deux ouvrages collectifs
la monnaie souveraine et la monnaie euh
la monnaie révélée par ces crises euh
évidemment avec la monnaie va la finance
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur la ce que
j'appelle dans la logique kénésienne
l'instabilité intrin sec de la finance
le risque systémique les crises
financières R et les régulations et
notamment plutôt puisque je suis
macroéconomiste l'aspect macroprudentiel
des régulations et enfin ma dernière
compétence c'est l'économie
internationale c'est normal puisque je
suis depuis 30 ans au CPI et que le CPI
est est l'organisme qui est vraiment
fait pour ça et donc globalisation
financière interdépendance taux de
change et évidemment économie européenne
conçu comme zone monétaire intern
national euh j'ai publié 24 livres plus
un alors le 1 est intéressant parce que
il nous intéresse directement en c'est
celui qui va sortir à la fin du mois et
qui s'appelle un New Deal pour l'Europe
et qui est coécrit avec un jeune
collaborateur alors sur les finances
publiques qu'est-ce que j'ai fait sur
les finances publiques depuis 2010 ben
j'ai eu la chance de diriger un groupe
de travail pour le compte de la Caisse
des dépôts qui a rédigé un rapport qui
s'appelle finances publiqu lespreu de
vérité pour la zone euro qui a été
présente qui a été terminé en décembre
2011 et qui a donné lieu à un collocque
au mois de janvier 2012 et après ça
c'est justement à la suite de ce cette
première base d'analyse que j'ai me suis
attaqué à approfondir ce travail dans ce
fameux livre que vous verrez bientôt un
New Deal pour l'Europe dans lequel nous
faisons une étude détaillée des
multiplicateurs budgétaires dans lequel
nous étudions les dynamique de
consolidation des dettes publiques dans
lequel nous cherchons à mettre en
évidence les pièges de l'austérité
lorsqu'on est dans un contexte de
désendettement massif du secteur privé
et euh ce livre se termine par deux
chapitres qui pose à mon avis les deux
questions essentielles pour tout le
monde quelle union politique pour la
zone euro et quelle croissance pour
l'Europe à la suite de ce livre et donc
tout récemment depuis le début de cette
année euh la Caisse des Dépôts a demandé
de poursuivre l'étude sur maintenant les
solutions concrètes pour consolider les
finances publiques et donc je dirige un
nouveau groupe pour le compte de la
Caisse des dépôts qui COM qui a commencé
ses travaux et euh qui est intéressant à
mon avis enfin l'optique qui est
justement il a il prend en compte les
expériences historiques ce que nous
allons faire c'est étudier les
expériences à la fois historiques et
géographiques des différents modes de
consolidation des finances publiques à
différentes périodes si vous voulez de
l'histoire et dans différents types de
sociétés
euh nous allons étudier notamment en
nous avons déjà commencé parce qu'il il
y a des collaborateurs qui font partie
de ce groupe qui ont étudié la France
depuis les années 1890 avec les
différentses types de consolidation
l'idée c'est de
définir dans différents contextes
macro-économiques quels sont les
principaux vecteurs de consolidation
c'est-à-dire vous en avez trois ou
quatre en fait hein le solld de primaire
créé d'un excédent primaire vous avez
les c entre le taux de croissance et le
taux d'intérêt donc ça c'est le plus
celui qui est le plus efficace si vous
êtes capable de réduire les taux
d'intérêt et de relancer la croissance
le processus se fait tout à fait
naturellement sans REM sans mettre en
cause l'emploi et sans mettre en cause
euh les les avantages économiques qu'on
obtient avec la croissance et le
troisème élément évidemment c'est la
dévaluation de la dette par l'inflation
si l'on veut éviter les défauts hein qui
est le 4e le 4e euh méthode en quelque
sorte de consolidation des finances
publiques donc étudier ces expériences
et voir en particulier à quel point
elles a été contrastées à travers les
crises qu'on subit dans les années
1990 d'un côté les Scandinaves de
l'autre côté le Japon nous donne
évidemment des à mon avis des pistes
intéressantes sur les types de solutions
à rechercher l'idée évidemment ça serait
de de de de faire un peu l'opposé de ce
qui est pour l'instant en cours en zone
euro c'est-à-dire une résolution
dynamique et offensive des finances
publiques à travers des politiques de
croissance ce que j'essaie de de montrer
dans le fameux livre un New Deal pour
l'Europe donc voilà voilà dans ce dans
ce contexte là et avec disons ce
background ce que le je peux penser du
Haut Conseil alors et à fonction de des
questions qu'a posé le président
Marini l'idée d'une règle budgétaire
intertemporelle est certainement une
très bonne idée pour quoi c'est une très
bonne idée c'est que lorsque vous avez
une dette publique qui a gonflé pour des
raisons exogènes qui a été la crise
financière et la prise en charge par les
États à à la fois des difficultés
bancaires et disons de d'essayer de
contrer la dépression qui allait se
produire en 2008 vous avez un
surgissement des des finances publiques
ce surgissement en se fait à chaque
crise financière à chaque crise
financière vous avez un transfert si
vous voulez de dett privé vers la dette
publique et se fait aussi dans les à
l'issue des guerres dans les donc c'est
ce type d'expérience montre que le
processus de consolidation est un
processus intertemporel long pour pas se
faire d'illusion le processus de
consolidation de situation de dette d'où
la nécessité de lois de programmation
intertemporelle pour définir des
trajectoires crédibles que les acteurs
économiques que ce soit les marchés
financiers ou les les acteurs de
l'économie réelle puisse percevoir comme
étant la ligne directrice que va suivre
le que va suivre les finances publiques
évidemment ceci concerne toute la zone
euro et ceci doit se faire à travers un
processus coopératif hein c'est pour ça
qu'and il a il va y avoir ce type de si
vous voulez de logique dans l'ensemble
des pays de la zone euro c'est le fameux
va et vien de coopération qu'on veut
tenter de faire à travers les semestres
européens de façon à avoir une certaine
cohérence euh euh passer de règles
automatique à une cohérence de
coopération en à travers si vous voulez
la la prise en charge par chaque État de
la même logique de programmation
intertemporelle si on veut faire avancer
l'Europe dans le domaine d'une union
budgétaire ce ce type de pratique euh
est évidemment crucial ça c'est donc
point important deuxièmement en effet le
solde structurel est une variable euh si
vous voulez construite euh c'est c'est
une variable logique mais il est déjà
utilisé si vous voulez ce qui est
utilisé derrière le sol structurel c'est
le PIB potentiel évidemment en en en
c'est-à-dire un niveau de PIB qui
correspond à une utilisation normale et
efficace de l'ensemble des ressources
productives dont disposent les
pays ce pi potentiel est déjà calculé
hein il est calculé par toutes les
institutions internationales il est
calculé par les banques centrales
puisque le P potentiel est essentiel à
la définition de la norme d'inflation et
à la politique monétaire donc on a
l'habitude d'utiliser ça le sol
structurel est aussi calculé évidemment
la question c'est certainement en d'un
étant donné l'incertitude qui règne sur
ces éléments d' améliorer les
déterminants si vous voulez le talon
d'ashield du sol structurel ce pourrait
être des discussions sans fin et des
controverses entre les gouvernements
nationaux et puis la Commission
européenne pour le définir et dire en
parti particulier pour les pays qui
seraient au-delà des des normes ou très
proches si vous voulez on risque d'avoir
évidemment des conflits de de vision non
moi je suis du bon côté alors que la
Commission pourrait dire non vous êtes
déjà en en déficit excessif ça c'est
évidemment la caractéristique qui est
inéliminable du fait que vous n'avez pas
une variable qui est observée de manière
évidente par
tous donc mais mais le point important
de sol structurel je dis c'est que il
est mesuré sur un cycle entier puisque
c'est sur le cycle entier que la
croissance si vous voulez potentielle
peut apparaître de manière euh
observable et en conséquence il est
forcément vers le futur pour nous hein
c'est-à-dire c'est qu'est-ce que va être
le la croissance potentielle du futur
qui est nécessaire à la définition du
sol structurel donc il y a forcément le
caractère mais les marchés financiers
aussi sont le sur futur tous les agents
économiques dans d'une économie
capitaliste vont vers le futur euh et la
question c'est en effet d'être crédible
sur euh ce type de
variable mais il me semble que pour que
ça fonctionne il faut plusieurs
conditions qui ne sont actuellement pas
réalisé et ça va poser sans doute des
problèmes la première c'est que le
Sixpack hein qui est l'ensemble des des
éléments de de contrainte que la
Commission a finalement qui a été validé
par contre il est contradictoire il est
contradictoire parce que cette
définition que j'ai donné se suffit à
elle-même c'est une vision que du
sold dépenses publiqu et des recettes
donc du budget sur le long terme et qui
est cohérent avec s'il est bien défini
avec une les caractéristiques de
croissance du pays mais dans le Sixpack
vous y ajouter des règles arbitraires
sans aucun sens économique qui est le
retour des fameux 3 % de maximum déficit
annuel
et le le fait de revenir mécaniquement à
60 % de det dett sur PIB aucun
économiste ne peut valider ça car ça n'a
pas de sens hein il faut bien se rendre
compte que ça n'a pas de sens ceci est
totalement arbitraire et le danger c'est
de voir une une pollution en quelque
sorte de la règle dynamique du sol
structurel pas en lui superposant des
éléments qui sont non pertinents par
rapport au processus que l'on cherche ça
c'est le premier élément qui me qui peut
faire problème le deuxième c'est que la
contrainte d'équilibre public est très
dure tel qu'elle est pensé - 05 % du PIB
le danger c'est de ne pas pouvoir
financer par d'être les investissements
publics productifs et ça ça m'inquiète
beaucoup
euh qu'est-ce qu' investissement public
productif monsieur le professeur alors
justement ceci je vais y revenir je vais
yevenenir hein parce que c'est
évidemment décisif décisif ce genre de
choses
euh mais enfin vous savez que la
recherche et l'éducation supérieure
etéducation en général en font partie
he et l'autre mais mais mais c'est plus
verrez c'est plus important que
ça l'autre élément c'est c'est que la la
contrainte en question est une
contrainte de régime permanent si vous
êtes au au PB potentiel au-delà du cycle
dans le cycle he à travers le cycle vous
devez respecter cette contrainte de
solde structurel mais on n'est pas dans
un régime permanent non pas seulement
parce qu'on est dans une situation
conjoncturelle
défavorable mais surtout parce que on
est dans une situation hérité de la
crise financière qui déforme très
profondément le cycle économique et qui
c'est c'est c'est pas par hasard si même
les États-Unis qui ont mené une
politique disons de recherche de
l'expansion massivement sont encore au
bout de 4 ans avec une politique
monétaire à taux zéro ça veut dire qu'on
est dans une situation exceptionnelle
mais une situation exceptionnelle qui
dure du fait de l'amplitude fantastique
de la crise que que que beaucoup de de
gens ne prennent pas en compte et en
conséquence il faut faire attention si
vous voulez au fait que il nous faut
revenir à un régime de croissance
normale où il y a un PIB potentiel qui
croit euh sauf si on admet que nous
sommes à 0 % de croissance sur le futur
on va pas admettre ça pour l'Europe en
conséquence le problème de la transition
structurelle est quelque chose
d'important qu'il faudra prendre en
compte euh pour pouvoir appliquer cette
règle si vous voulez en question car
elle POS elle peut poser problème euh
l'idée cruciale tout de même elle est
dans cette expérience historique dont je
vous ai parlé c'est que euh pour
inverser une courbe de dette je reviens
il faut une croissance suffisante pour
une création nette d'emploi he sans le
sans lequel on n'y arrive pas aucun
outil si vous voulez de contournement de
ce type de contrainte macro ne permet de
résoudre le problème à sa place quoi
hein donc le problème c'est de que la
que les finances publiques participent à
une politique de croissance et de ce
point de vue-là je reviens sur l'idée
vous savez il y a deux théories de la la
croissance l'une qui est dite exogène
c'est-à-dire que les déterminants
essentiels de la croissance viennent de
l'accumulation du capital et viennent
d'un train disons de de ce qui tombe du
ciel on suppose que le progrès technique
tombe du ciel et puis maintenant de
c'est dépassé ça on a une théorie de la
croissance endogène et alors dans la
théorie de la croissance endogène euh
toutes les dépenses publiqu ne se valent
pas il y a en effet des dépenses
publiques de toutes sortes euh vous avez
des publi de fonctionnement vous avez
dépenses publiques d'équité et vous avez
des dépenses publiques qui constituent
le capital collectif de la nation en et
qui sont des éléments de croissance et
ce que je voudrais c'est qu'il y ait des
travaux qui soi fait sur la structure
des dépenses de la même que il soit fait
sur la structure des recettes en terme
d'équité comme en terme de croissance
toutes les recettes ne se valent pas non
plus la propontion à consommer n'est pas
la même selon tel ou tel type de mesures
fiscal et de la même manière vous avez
des mesures fiscales qui sont qui sont
des incitateurs de croissance et
d'autres qui ne le sont pas et ceci
n'est pas très très bien étudié je veux
dire queil y a il y a vraiment un
travail économique à faire à mon avis
sur la structure du budget c'est
exactement ce qu'on fait les Suédois ils
ont non pas cherché à tout prix à
réduire le budget par l'austérité
lorsqu'ils ont eu cette crise financière
énorme mais ils ont profondément
restructurer le budget dans le sens des
dépenses justement productives
c'est-à-dire ils ont dit la chose
suivante nous avons maintenant arrivé à
la pointe technologique à la frontière
technologique la frontière technologique
à l'époque c'était clairement les
industries d'information ils ont fait un
effort massif les finlandais aussi qui
était une économie agraire dans les
années 80 en moins de 10 ans ces
économies sont arrivées à la pointe de
l'innovation technologique par une
restructuration des dépenses publiques
voilà ce que je
pense et que je reviens sur la la la la
dernière idée c'est que ces procédures
nationales ne seront vraiment efficace
que s'il y a une synergie positive
c'est-à-dire si elles sont intégrées
dans dans ces fameux semestres européens
avec la visée d'être une phase
transitoire vers quelque chose qui sera
une union budgétaire he je ve dire pour
moi c'est un processus de d'évolution
vers une union budgétaire et cette union
budgétaire veut dire à terme un trésor
européen capable de mener une politique
coordonnée des budgets des différents
pays et de dépasser les limites qu'on a
rencontré du fait de
notre de d'institution faible en quelque
sorte de coopération en Europe mon avis
c'est c'est c'est pour répondre à leur
véritable rôle ces différents conseil de
au conseil de finances publies doivent
disons permettre de participer à au
renforcement des institutions
budgétaires de l'ensemble de la zone
euro je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Professeur alors à présent les deux
rapporteurs généraux
euh commission des finances et
commission des affaires sociales vont
vous questionner Monsieur François
Marc merci Monsieur
président bienvenue à Michel Aglietta
chacun connaît les les exigences qui ont
conduit à mettre sur pied ce Haut
Conseil des finances publiques dans
notre
pays il y a des incertitudes c'est
incontestable il y
a s'agissant des prévisions économiques
et des modalités de mise en œuvre des
corrections
trajectoire bien des doutes sur la bonne
façon de procéder et le Haut Conseil a
vocation à éclairer d' alors on peut se
réjouir que le Sénat est proposé Michel
Aglietta et Mathilde Lemoine qui sont
des économiste connu et je crois que
pouvoir le dire il y aura pas de vote
donc je peux le dire avant je crois PIR
dire que c'est un bon choix du Sénat
concernant l'un et l'autre cela étant il
y a dans la miss sur sur pied de cet
organisme des questions qui restent
posées puisque il s'agit d'initier un
nouveau processus de réflexion et
d'évaluation dès lors on peut se poser
quelques questions et Michel Aglietta
pourra nous éclairer sur son point de
vue à ce sujet j'ai deux trois questions
pour ma part la première sur
l'articulation des fonctions de membres
du Haut Conseil avec celle d'économiste
parce que euh pourriez être amené soit
parce que vous êtes questionné
publiquement soit dans le cadre de vos
activités
professionnelles à vous prononcer sur
des sujets rentrant dans le champ du des
avis du Haut Conseil par exemple
s'agissant des des prévisions de
croissance dans ces conditions comment
entendez-vous donner suite à
d'éventuelles sollicitations si votre
opinion n'est pas celle euh qu'aura
retenu le Haut Conseil dans son avis
parce que chacun des membres du Haut
Conseil peut avoir un avis personnel qui
puisse différer des conclusions et des
communications publiques donc
comment coordonner comment harmoniser c
un un point de questionnement pour
nous deuxièmement s'agissant du
fonctionnement du Haut Conseil
euh on sait que l'article 12 de la loi
organique prévoit que lorsqu'il exprime
un avis sur une prévision de croissance
le Haut Conseil tient compte des
prévisions d'un ensemble d'organismes
dont il
établit la
liste et il la rend publique donc pour
nous la question est de savoir dans
quelle
mesure on peut considérer que le Conseil
le Haut Conseil pourrait s'écarter des
prévisions de ces organismes qu'on a
retenu on en a rendu publique la liste
et donc on on s'appuie en principe sur
la synthèse des la vie de ces
organismes mais peut-on s'écarter dans
quelle
mesure selon vous des prévisions du
gouvernement qui seraient supérieur à
cell du Haut Conseil entraînerait-elle
forcément un avis défavorable
ou le Haut Conseil devrait-il accepter
un écart dès lors que celui-ci ne
dépasserait pas un certain seuil enfin c
une une question sur le mode de
fonctionnement du Haut Conseil qui nous
interroge euh je vais pas rentrer sur le
fond des des questions que vous avez
introduites dans votre propos liminire
et qui aurait pu nous amener ce matin à
des discussions fortes intéressantes
monsieur le Président sur le New Deal
pour l'Europe vous n avez un peu alléché
avec les quelques idées que vous nous
avez déjà soumis qui vont être dans
votre prochain ouvrage ou sur la Chine
dont vous avez traiter le cas spécifique
d'une façon tout à fait
remarquable mais mais néanmoins sans
entrer dans tous ces sujets peut-être
une question de fond une question sur
les méthodes parce que l'article 13
organique prévoit que le Haut Conseil
rend un avis sur l'estimation du PIB
potentiel sur laquelle repose la
trajectoire de soldes structurel des
futurs projets de loi de programmation
et finances publies et qui sera utilisé
par le Haut conseil donc pour apprécier
le respect de cette
trajectoire alors quelle est selon vous
la méthode la plus robuste pour évaluer
payb potentiel approche statistique ou
approche économétrique et dans le cas où
la trajectoire de PIB potentiel précisé
par la loi de programmation cessait
d'être crédible par exemple parce qu'une
croissance effective durable faible ind
duré une baisse du Pay potentiel le Haut
Conseil devrait-il compléter son analyse
par une autre trajectoire de PIB
potentiel donc c'est une question de
fond sur la méthode de travail est-ce
que au fond le Haut Conseil peut
corriger la copie en quelque sorte du
fait des éclairage pertinent qu'il y a
en son sein et dès lors donner une toute
autre dimension aux orientations
politiques inévitablement appelé à
mettre en œuvre de nouvelles
orientations donc c'est un peu sur
l'étendue du champ de préconisation là
que se pose cette question enfin une
dernière question si vous voulez bien
sur les CIR constance exceptionnelle
parce que l'article 23 de la loi
organique institue un mécanisme de
correction trouvant à s'appliquer
lorsque sont constatés des écarts
importants par rapport à la trajectoire
du sol
structurel alors on est autorisé à
s'écarter momentanément de cette
trajectoire lorsqu'ils sont confrontés
ces États à des circonstances
exceptionnelles
et cette notion de circonstance
exceptionnelle n'est pas précisément
définie par les texte donc il y a une
marge d'interprétation visiblement pour
le Haut conseil sur ce point et il est
important peut-être qu'on sache jusqu'où
le conseil peut s'autoriser à aller sur
l'interprétation de ces circonstances
exceptionnelles et si vous pouviez nous
donner votre sentiment sur ce point ceci
nous éclairer fort utilement voilà
monsieur le Président quelques questions
élémentaires pour éclairer nos collègues
quelques petites questions quelques
petites questions voilà alors monsieur
le rapporteur général Yv daudini
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Professeur mes chers collègues
permettez-moi peut-être à cet instant
après madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales de de
rappeler l'importance déterminante des
dépenses de protection sociale dans
l'évolution des dépenses publiques et
dans la situation financière globale des
comptes publics alors je l'illustre par
deux points les prestations de
protection sociale versé par les régimes
d'assurance social et les
administrations publiques centrales et
locales tel qu'évalué par les comptes de
la protection sociale représenté en 2011
plus de 50 % de l'ensemble des dépenses
des administrations publiquequ soit 557
milliards d'euros sur 1096 milliards
d'euros et les administrations de
sécurité sociale représentaient 0,6
points de PIB donc 12,2 milliards
d'euros de déficit public en 2011 par
rapport donc à 5,2 points de PIB pour la
totalité rappelez peut-être aussi à cet
instant les pouvoirs attribués au au
Conseil des finances publiques dans la
sphère sociale par la loi organique le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
intervient en amont des PLF SS de
l'année et des et des éventuels PLF R et
CS sur les hypothèses de croissance et
il peut également se prononcer sur les
objectifs pluriannuel de dépenses des
régimes obligatoires de base de sécurité
sociale et sur l'évolution pluriannuelle
de longam dans le casadre de l'examen
des projets de loi de programmation
alors Monsieur le Professeur quelques
questions qui n'appellent peut-être pas
aujourd'hui ce matin des réponses
définitives mais qui ouvrent à mon sens
des champs d'expression comment
définirz-vous la spécificité des
finances sociales au sein des finances
publiques cette évident cette éventuelle
spécificité pourra-t-elle selon vous
être prise en compte dans le cadre des
travaux du Haut Conseil deuxème question
bien que cette question alors là c'est
foi dépasse largement le casadre de
cette audition je souhaiterais connaître
votre avis sur la soutenabilité
financière à moyen terme de notre
système de protection
sociale le redressement nécessaire des
comptes publics vous paraît-il dans le
contexte économique actuel compatible
avec le maintien d'un système de
protection sociale de qualité et 4e
question la définition de perspective
pluriannuelle pour les dépenses
consacrées au risque vieillesse et
famille comme il en existe déjà pour les
dépenses d'assurance maladie au travers
de long d'â vous paraîtreit-elle
pertinente et puis monsieur le
professeur j'aurais peut-être plus ne
vous poser qu'une seule question à vous
qui êtes connu pour vos travaux donc
consacrés aux différentes crises vous
avez rappelé euh dans le propos au
préalable comment analysez-vous la crise
du financement de notre protection
sociale et le cas échéant quels seraient
les moyens d'y remédier VO monsieur le
professeur c'est une gageure de répondre
en un temps limité à des questions aussi
aussi fondamentales peut-être
devrons-nous madame la Présidente
organiser d'autres audition et je je je
ne dirais pas je le crains au contraire
je pense que nous pouvons abord ça avec
plaisir et un avis qu'est-ce que c'est
professeur est-ce que c'est oui non
favorable défavorable un ensemble de
considérant un chiffre substitué à un
autre la complexité dont nous avons déjà
parlé qui revient dans les questions les
avis doivent être motivés ça c'est
certain c'estàdire un avis pe peut
aboutir à un jugement sur si vous voulez
bien for la né cité de correction tel
que le voit le Haut Conseil mais très
motivé donc ça suppose une analyse
approfondie prenant en compte l'ensemble
comme vous l'avez dit des de la
connaissance du moment en en tel quelle
sorte des de l'ensemble des
organisations qui travaillent sur cet
environnement macro-économique alors bon
pour ce qui concerne la le fait de la
manière de s'exprimer en dehors non pas
en tant que membre du Haut Conseil mais
en tant qu'économiste euh bon moi moi ça
me ça me me gêne beaucoup moins que
d'autres d'une certaine manière je
dirais pourquoi parce que je travaille
dans un organisme qui travaille sur le
sur l'économie mondiale et pas et pas
directement sur l'économie française en
ce qui concerne ma ma mon travail en
tant qu'économiste du CPI euh je ne suis
je suis plus un économiste qui est du
long terme que du du conjoncturel et par
conséquent je n'ai pas j'ai jamais à
m'exprimer sur la conjoncture si vous
voulez euh de manière directe et
publique enfin hein c'est c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui pour moi est un un
outil d'analyse par rapport au problème
structurel qui qui est ma préoccupation
principale donc ça ne devrait pas poser
des des des problèmes insurmontbles mais
en fait vous avez raison il faut faire
il va falloir faire très attention parce
que les les journalistes mettent très
vite des étiquettes et c'est très
difficile d'apparaître à un moment donné
comme étant en si vous voulez autre
chose que ce qu'on est là en tant que
euh personnalité officielle euh c'est en
effet quelque chose à prendre en
considération alors ce qu'il faut penser
c'est que vis-à-vis de de problème des
écarts faut se méfierêre il y a
exceptionnel par rapport à un so
structurel mais puisque le sold est
structurel il y a la situation
conjoncturelle et ça c'est normal et on
revient à toujours à ce problème
c'est-à-dire si nous avons nous arrivons
à à montrer que on est dans une
situation c'est quand même pas difficile
à montrer aujourd'hui euh avec un
chômage massif avec des capacités de
production inemployé énorme ça veut dire
qu'on est dans une situation
conjoncturelle dépressive par rapport à
la à au PIB normal où existe le sol
structurel et à ce moment-là c'est pour
ça que je parlais de ces fameux 3 % à ce
moment-là dans une gestion dynamique à
moyen terme des finances publiques il
faut évidemment accepter de la
flexibilité conjoncturelle et la
question c'est que il faut l'accepter
dans les deux sens ce que généralement
les gouvernements n'avaient pas fait
dans les dans dans les années de
croissance élevée qui était les années
euh fin des ann début des années 2000
fin des années 90 c'est-à-dire il faut
faire au contraire de l'excédent dans la
phase de haute conjoncture car si on
veut maintenir un PIP potentiel après
une période de basse conjoncture il faut
passer au-dessus au-dessus du PIB
potentiel sinon ça veut dire que le PIB
potentiel décroit dans le temps et c'est
justement ce qui s'est passé en Europe
si vous prenez décennies après décenni
une mesure expose du PIB potentiel vous
trouvez qu'aux États-Unis depuis les
années 60 il est PE près constant en
tour de 2 2,5 3 % chez nous il a baissé
décennies après des chez nous de toute
la zone euro hein baisser décennies
après décennies et on est dans les
années 2000 à un PIB potentiel qui ne
doit pas dépasser sans doute un 5 % et
donc la question la question de fond
elle est là quoi à c'est c'est pour ça
que je parlais de politique de
croissance que à mon avis c'est au
Conseil doit si vous voulez introduire
des idées en faveur de ça à voilà c'est
ça et alors l'exceptionnel par rapport
au au au solld de structurel lui-même
c'est ce dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que quand vous êtes dans
une situation qui est un impact d'une
crise financière qui a une longue une
portée extrêmement longue dans le temps
hein et et le fait en particulier rendez
compte que seule l'Allemagne depuis a
retrouvé le niveau de production qu'elle
avait en
2007 nous sommes encore en dessous
largement ne parlons pas de l'Italie et
cetera donc on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle enfin euh et c'est là le
le problème de de fond on n'est pas sûr
que en ce qui concerne la doctrine qui
se trouve à la commission qui ait une
prise en compte profonde de ça voilà la
difficulté euh pour mais donc je veux
dire que la flexibilité conjoncturelle
c'est à nous aussi de de dire qu'elle
existe he et c'est justement il faut se
servir euh du caractère dynamique de
cette règle pour dire attention il faut
pas lui euh lui lui lui lui en
superposer d'autres qui n'ont pas de
sens al voilà voilà ce que je je voulais
parler alors les méthodes d'estimation
et bien bon vous savez il y a il y a des
elles sont déjà enfin elles sont rodés
par les les institutions à la fois
international et par par l'INC et cetera
à à il y a de deux types de méthodes
fondamentalement l'une qui est
statistique c'est-à-dire qui consiste à
à à analyser les les les données
temporelles du passé et à extraire la
tendance hein extraire la tendance à
partir d' euh de l'ensemble de ces
données de façon à séparé l'amplitude et
le et et la périodicité des fluctuations
conjoncturelles et le trend quoi
aujourd'hui si vous voulez c'est autour
de de 5 ans à peu près la durée d'un
cycle euh et donc on peut extraire ça de
mais voyez que vous avez une expression
du PIB potentiel qui est peu informatif
sur le plan de la de ce qui est derrière
quoi qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui produit
le PIB euh elle dit simplement que en
effet de d'une tendance historique du de
l'évolution de la conjoncture on peut
extraire si vous voulez cette idée de
tendance la deuxième c'est évidemment
l'économétrie sur la fonction de
production c'est-à-dire penser que
l'économie produit le PIB à partir de
ressources productives le travail le
capital la
technologie qu'on peut améliorer alors
vous avez des fonctions de production
qui l'améliore avec une une
représentation suffisamment intéressante
du capital humain et cetera ça ça me
paraît évidemment la meilleure méthode
euh euh elle n'est pas elle est
appliquée dans les recherches dans les
études mais elle n'est pas évidemment
dans la mesure si vous voulez pour la
conjoncture de ce qu'est le le PIP
potentiel mais néanmoins elle doit
éclairer et aujourd'hui dans une période
comme la nôtre où on a on a besoin en
fait d'une transformation du mode de
croissance manifestement en euh et donc
l'étude des facteurs de production qui
sont nécessaires pour la croissance à
venir me paraît un élément qui doit
nourrir la réflexion même si elle
n'apparaît pas n'est pas un élément
direct de la détermination si vous
voulez du PIB pour le pour pour cette
année par exemple mais je pense qu'il
faut faire des études sur la croissance
assez importante voilà pour la deuxième
pour les questions les questions
sociales moi ce que je dirais c'est
qu'en effet les les finances sociales
ont une spécificité en ce sens que je je
je je je pense à à la notion de dette
sociale à ce qui est pas assez pensé si
vous voulez euh la dette sociale c'est
la dette de tous les les citoyens
vis-à-vis de la nation dans son ensemble
car ce sont c'est l'ensemble des biens
et service public euh euh qui constitue
le vivre ensemble enfin qui nous qui qui
fait que la société a une cohérence euh
et a une capacité de de se prolonger
dans le temps en et donc pour moi la
notion de dette sociale c'est la dette
des citoyens vis-à-vis euh euh de la
nation dans son ensemble dans lequel les
institutions sont les médiateurs en
quelque sorte euh euh les les les les
médiateurs de de cette dette et c'est
d'ailleurs de cette manière-là que il
faut analyser la dette publique comme
très différente des dettes privées la
définir fondamentalement tout au moins
le danger c'est bien ce qui s'est passé
c'est-à-dire que quand la dette est est
est détenue par des non-résidents vous
avez une une dégradation de la notion de
dette sociale en dette privée en quelque
sorte mais si elle est détenue par des
résidents et si l'État est non
défaillant et si justement il laisse sa
sa trajectoire
d'évolution en dans le temps de la dette
est soutenable à long terme la dette
publique est un transfert
intergénérationnel de l'impôt pas plus
hein en effet ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que si on fait des investissements
publics c'est-à-dire on constitue un
capital caractéristique de la de la
dette sociale et bien il est normal que
ceux qui en bénéficieront le plus du
fait que le
capital ne produit ses effets que dans
le temps en en en en fasse partie du
financement de cette dette c'est ça là
profondément le sens profond de la dette
publique hein cette c'est quelque chose
qui exprime une solidarité dans le dans
ce cadre là il est clair que la la les
comptes sociaux évidemment sont les
meilleurs représentant en en de de cette
dette sociale et de ce point de vue-là
ne peuvent pas être traité comme si vous
voulez de de de de la finance privée
alors le problème c'est celui des
retraites fondamentalement hein un un un
la question de de de de de de des
retraites parce qu'elle elle introduit
ce que j'ai dit ce transfert
intergénérationnel et cette solidarité
dans le temps en et là on tombe sur le
évidemment la question de la de de de
sa soutenabilité de la soutenabilité des
comptes sociaux évidemment incorporé
dans la soutenabilité générale de la
dette publique euh mais elle pose du
fait de la nature si vous voulez d'être
le cœur de la dette sociale un problème
spécifique vis-à-vis du caractère
intergénérationnel donc essentiellement
du problème des retraites le problème
des retraites on sait bien que du fait
du vieillissement il doit être
probablement je pense que ce que ce que
que ce qui est en train d'être fait me
semble la la seule manière possible
ensuite le problème c'est quand même les
modalités mais une une des une réforme
progressive dans le temps quoi c'est
c'est il peut pas avoir un Big Bang je
pense sur la réforme des retraites hein
c'est un processus encore une fois qui
qui pose vraiment crucial pour la
cohésion de la nation en et et donc mais
on va forcément vers un un un mix
probablement en probablement hein d'une
certaine augmentation encore de de de
l'âge de la retraite et euh de la et des
contributions en en mais moi moi j'ai
toujours pensé malgré tout que ce qu'il
faudrait pour l'ensemble de la
l'ensemble des comptes sociaux c'est
redéfinir ce qui est contributif et ce
qui n'est pas
contributif de façon à ne pas faire
peser sur le le rendement du travail
finalement la totalité des dépenses et
donc faire comme l'ont fait en
particulier suédois c'est-à-dire
fiscaliser la partie non contributive de
la dette sociale de façon à alléger le
moi j'ai j'ai par je pensais aussi à
d'autres choses si vous voulez parce que
je travaille quand même pas mal sur
l'environnement c'est-à-dire
cette idée mais mais ça suppose en effet
vis-à-vis du politique une opportunité
de le faire c'est-à-dire que la
substitution taxe carbone par rapport à
baisse du coût du travail me semble
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
positif vis-à-vis de la croissance
future et vis-à-vis de la compétitivité
donc il y a un ensemble de réformes je
pense qui qui est crucial je ne sais pas
si le Haut Conseil devra mais
probablement il peut donner un certain
nombre d'idées de pistes sur ce sujet
voilà voilà ce que je je pensais sur les
question question que vous m'avez posé
merci infiniment monsieur le professeur
je crois que vous nous avez montré votre
grande liberté d'esprit et j'allais dire
votre caractère inclassable selon les
rubriques habituelles et qui ont cours
dans les dans les assemblées et alors il
y a plusieurs demandes de parole nous
allons tcher d'interrompre à 11h si vous
le voulez bien au plus tard pour
entendre entre madame le mooine et alors
j'ai une demande de parole de Monsieur
Bourdin tout d'abord
oui merci Monsieur monsieur le Président
tout d'abord je me réjouis de la la
proposition de désignation de Michel
Aglietta dont j'ai lu quelques travaux
donc don j'apprécie la qualité des
travaux
et mais ça c'est pas ma question bien
évidemment je ma question est la
suivante Michel Aglietta vous vous
l'avez dit et vous l'avez rappelé et vos
vre argumentation le prouve vous êtes un
spécialiste du long terme hein vous êtes
pour un spécialiste de la théorie longue
mais là vous allez désigné dans un dans
un organisme qui est plutôt spécialisé
dans le court terme puisqu'on vous
demande de vous prononcer sur le le le
taux de croissance à venir dans le cadre
du des lois de finances et je je vous
demande comment vous allez faire pour
atterrir parce que je suis moi-même
président de la délégation à la
prospective et c'est c'est c'est
une il y a des méthodes que que que je
connais dans ce domaine là mais c'est
évidemment plus délicat ensuite pour se
retrouver dans dans dans le court terme
vous avez parlé bien des fois tout à
l'heure de la croissance potentielle
hein qui est un concept de long terme
hein et et comment allez vous faire pour
vous retrouver dans dans dans d'autres
dispositions et dans d'autres
contraintes pour donner votre avis sur
le taux de croissance de de l'année à
venir c'est ma première question la la
la deuxième question le Haut Conseil
bien sûr j'imagine hein
aura bien sûr il aura à se prononcer
mais il s'appuiera pour cela j'imagine
sur les travaux effectués travaux de
type économétrique de différents
organismes et et et et et et comment
comptez-vous procéder pour à travers
toutes ces prévisions qui après tout
sont sont souvent bien justifié euh
trouver une
proposition différente originale est-ce
que vous allez travailler sur ces sur
ces modèles des des des des organismes
de recherche sur le court terme ou
est-ce que vous vous allez vous
prononcer en fonction de ce que vous
steriez peut-être d'un d'un d'un euh
d'une panoplie de moyen qui vous serait
attribué et et lorsque vous aurez à vous
prononcer j'imagine que ça sera bien
difficile de dire voilà pour l'année
prochaine le taux de croissance est
probablement de de 1 % allez prenons un
exemple ça vous sera difficile et donc
j'imagine que vous proposerez une
fourchette et quelle est l'étendue de la
fourchette que vous estimez possible de
de de retenir pour pour nous aider à
travailler sur la loi de finance
merci beaucoup à Monsieur Bourdin la
parole est à Jean-Paul et morine merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Professeur mes chers collègues je eu
l'occasion de vous auditionner comme
président de la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat à plusieurs
reprises moi je vous ai bien écouté et
que mes collègues de la majorité
d'aujourd'hui ne se froissent pas je ne
vise pas le gouvernement nous sommes
dans une période où il n'y aura pas de
croissance donc notre pays est en train
de s'appauvrir la dette augmente le
chômage augmente je voulais simplement
monsieur le professeur vous avez rappelé
les dépenses publiques que dans les
dépenses publiques il y a du
fonctionnement il y a de
l'investissement productif et quand on
regarde des ratios et vous faites des
comparaison dans le cadre de la
mondialisation en France nous avons un
taux de prélèvement obligatoire et pas
le procès du gouvernement à hauteur de
46 % du produit intérieur brut mais nous
avons en même temps un taux de 56 % pour
les dépenses publiques alors qu'un pays
comme l'Allemagne se situe plutôt à 45 %
et si on prend des références comme les
États-Unis ou la Grande-Bretagne ces
dépenses publiques représentent 41 % de
leur produit intérieur brut alors
comment interprétez-vous ces ratios
d'une d'une façon macro-économique et
puis mon ma deuxième question vous avez
évoqué et on évoque en permanence la
croissance est-ce que la surévaluation
de l'euro n'est-elle pas un handicap
pour avoir une croissance dans le
casadre de l'Union
européenne merci beaucoup à Jean-Paul et
Maine y a-t-il d'autres demandes de
parole parmi nos nos collègues alors je
n'en vois pas je me permettrai monsieur
le professeur peut-être pour terminer
une question un peu facétieuse euh tout
à l'heure vous avez évoqué la notion
d'investissement public productif et
vous avez laissé entendre que vous
feriez un commentaire et qu'à vos yeux
l'innovation l'enseignement
supérieur même s'il s'agit de dépenses
de
salaire était sans doute à qualifier
d'investissement public productif
et est-ce qu'il n'est pas un peu
paradoxal encore une fois la question
est facétieuse il faut la prendre au 2e
degré paradoxal que les professeurs
d'université nous disent toujours
cela voilà c'est ma ma
question
jedonnez-o il y a un repentir du docteur
Milon excusez-moi monsieur le professeur
euh dans le cadre de la commission des
affffaires sociales nous avons eu à à
gérer beaucoup de crisees du médicament
et beaucoup de scandales le scandale du
Médiator du viox de la gripe H1 et
cetera dans le cadre de nos travaux nous
avons fait un peu de toilettage au
niveau des agences et dans cadre de ces
agences nous avons demandé aux
professeurs qui participent à ces
agences de ne pas avoir de lien
d'intérêt avec laboratoire
pharmaceutique vous avez dit dans vos
propos préliminaires que vous aviez des
liens d'intérêt avec groupe ama est-ce
que ces liens d'intérêt risquent de
faire un conflit d'intérêt si vous êtes
nommé au
comité le professeur à vous la parole
pour répondre à l'ensemble des questions
je termine je prends la la la dernière
parce que plus rapide à à répondre non
non j'ai pas de de lien d'intérêt j'ai
je suis j'ai fait des recherches et je
suis rémunéré sur des contrats de
recherche pour le bah oui mais je suis
rémunéré pour un travail de
d'économistes pur et simple c'est pas ce
qu'on peut appeler lien d'intérêt je
veux dire c'est je pense pas euh je
pense que d'autres économistes vous sont
beaucoup plus liés à des à des
organismes financiers que je ne le suis
non je pense pas véritablement hein tout
ce que je fais c'est de la recherche
macro euh euh dans le cadre de cette de
cette entreprise comme je le pendant
vous savez avant j'ai fait j'ai toujours
voulu rester un peu dans la finance
parce que j'avais besoin de faire ce
d'avoir une une connaissance pratique
j'ai toujours de toute ma carrière et
mélanger le travail universitaire et le
travail de consultants dans des
organismes où je puisse avoir une
connaissance pratique je travaillis 8
ans à la Banque de France pour ça
pendant la période de préparation de
l'Union monétaire et en 98 à partir du
momentù l'union monétaire était faite
ben je suis allé chercher d'autres
organismes dans lequel je pouvais
poursuivre ma recherche sur la finance
hein c'est vraiment ma ma préoccupation
est purement de recherche euh et en
particulier je n'ai aucun vous avez des
économistes qui sont partis de conseil
d'administration de de banque et cetera
j'ai absolument rien de tel hein donc je
ça s'appelle pas lien d'intérêt à mon
avis hein euh bon alors enfin tout au
moins c'est comme ça que je je je vois
les choses et euh et et d'ailleurs dans
dans dans plupart de mes travaux vous
verrez que il y a je pas toujours je je
cite pas toujours Groupama comme
une référence de mes appartenances ça
dépend de de des choses si vous voulez
je fais très attention à ça euh alors
revenons au problème des de la de disons
de la l'expression de la croissance et
du jugement queon devra
fournir bon la première chose est
probablement enfin oui c'est que les
gens ne ne veulent toujours en
particulier c'est le cas des ça doit
être le cas du gouvernement aussi mais
en tout cas c'est le cas des
journalistes il pensent que euh il y a
pas d'incertitude et qu'il faut leur
donner des chiffres précis et puis euh
vous avez des gens qui commentent si si
c'est - 02 ou + 02 par rapport à ce qui
était prévu considère que c'est il y a
un changement et qu'on s'est trompé et
cetera il faut arriver à faire prendre
ente à faire avoir une démarche
probabiliste quoi en quelque sorte sur à
tout le monde hein je veux dire
c'est-à-dire qu'enet en effet fourchette
certainement et même dans certains cas
d'incertitude profonde et de de débat si
vous voulez contradictoire et en
particulier de vue contradictoire des
différents organismes euh internationaux
ou nationaux qui sont euh qui produisent
des chiffres sur la macroéconomie je
pense qu' à certains cas il faut dire
bah il peut y avoir plusieurs scénarios
parce que là nous sommes dans une
incertitude sur laquelle nous avons même
du mal à mettre une probabilité euh euh
quantifiée en quelque sorte hein et ça
il faut vraiment que les gens s'en
rendre compte hein je dire euh et et
mais le point important aussi du Haut
Conseil me semble-t-il c'est de dire que
euh le processus de mesure de la
croissance potentielle n'oublions pas
que c'est une croissance anticipée sur 5
ans à venir
euh il va il peut être modifié à partir
des informations nouvelles qui arrivent
quoi il y a l'apprentissage si vous
voulez des informations nouvelles et la
le fait de pouvoir modifier les les les
le processus et modifier les les avis
éventuellement ça il faut arriver à
prendre en compte l'incertitude de la
meilleure manière possible pour ce qui
est du euh de la on fera certainement
une confrontation en effet des
différentes prévisions par les
organismes si vous voulez autoriser qui
soit le Fond monétaire qui soit la
commission qui soit l' FC qui soit l'INC
qui soit le consensus financier des des
banques d'affaires qui aussi produisent
des éléments hein de conjoncture et et
et c'est notre le travail d'arriver à
dégager en effet ce qui sont les fites
stylisés les plus importants qui peuvent
nous assoir noir une hypothèse de de
croissance pour l'année qui vient mais
dans le cas n'oubliez pas que si c'est
une croissance potentielle et son
écart je pense l'exemple de 2013 si vous
voulez hein il y a quand même un
problème tout sans exception en les
organismes qui est important disons
avait une fourchette entre - 02 et + 0,5
de croissance en quelque sorte pour la
France donc afficher une croissance
au-delà de ça devient du volontarisme
c'est pas peut-être que que qu' on a le
droit de le faire et que que le
gouvernement peut le faire mais à ce
moment-là c'est plus une prévision c'est
plus une prévision quand vous tombez en
dehors de toutes les fourchettes de tous
les organisme avéré vous êtes plus dans
le cas d'une prévision et à ce moment-là
vous tombez sur des difficultés de
crédibilité c'est ça dont je parlais
hein c'est le fait d'avoir des des
hypothèses soit donc notre rôle c'est
d'essayer de se tenir dans les
hypothèses qui peuvent apparaître
crédibles par rapport à l'état de la
connaissance du moment et de faire jouer
en effet l'idée que on vit dans un monde
d'incertitude et cet état de la
connaissance il doit évoluer au fur et à
mesure ou de nouvelles informations
arrivent et on doit rester dynamique
vis-à-vis de ce sujet pour ce qui
concerne donc le problème dépenses
publiques et cetera bah il y il y a une
dérive de long terme qui s'est produite
et qui vient évidemment en grande partie
du fait de cet affaiblissement de la
croissance vous la trouvez partout hein
je veux dire vous le trouvez dans les
dépenses sociales mais vous le trouvez
justement dans les dépenses d'innovation
et cetera vous verrez dans le livre il y
a une comparaison internationale de euh
disons à part de travaux de l'OCD sur
l'intensité de la Recherche
Développement le ratio recherche
développement sur
PIB depuis les années 60 ce que vous
trouvez c'est que les deux pays en
Europe se sont affaiblis lentement mais
sûrement quoi en quelque sorte année
après année c'est la France et le
Royaume-Uni c'estàdire les Royaume-Uni
depuis les années 80 la France depuis
1995 où ce ratio baisse mais il baisse
pas nécessairement du point de vue de la
de la des dépenses de R de l'État c'est
le rapport total dont je parle c'est les
entreprises qui ne font pas assez de de
recherche développement et de très loin
je veux dire il y a un manque de
recherche développement entreprise en
France qui est
considérable il va en parti avec le fait
que notre innovation en en bottom up
c'est-à-dire partant en des des
PMA n'arrivve pas à suffisamment de
maturité parce que il y a la plupart il
y a beaucoup trop de mortalité de PME
nous créons autant de PME par rapport à
la population que les Américains mais
pour passer des PME aux ETI hein
c'est-à-dire les grosses PME qui en
effet peuvent consolider l'innovation en
en tel que ça existe en
Allemagne nous n'avons donc nous n'avons
pas de système d'innovation suffisamment
organisé et créant si vous voulez une
continuité dans l'innovation dite
incrémentale c'est-à-dire qui se fait au
f F et à mesure de l'évolution de la la
concurrence et donc là c'est un problème
de de modifier la nature du financement
aussi hein bon je sais pas si ça va être
de nos compétences mais en tout cas moi
c'est des choses que qui m'apportent
beaucoup et sur lequel je travaille pas
mal donc revenons maintenant aux
dépenses publiques social il y a eu en
effet si vous voulez quand vous avez un
chômage permanent et croissant tel que
nous l'avons avec une croissance qui
s'est
éteinte vous vous avvez forcément une
une baisse des recettes et une montée
des des c'est c'est c'est vraiment
quelque chose très important or la crise
nous fait ça non pas seulement comme si
c'était qu'une modification
conjoncturelle et rebond en en on arrive
à passer ce cap mais c'est pas ça encore
une fois depuis 2007 nous avons un un
affaiblissement massif de nos capacités
productives une montée du chômage
irrépressible et donc forcément nous
avons une augmentation des dépenses
sociales qui un malfou à se financer
donc c'est pour ça qu'on retrouve on
retombe sans arrêt sur ce problème de du
minimum de croissance sans lequel on a
on peut pas arriver à sortir de de la
situation pour ça que je met je mets
surtout l'accent là-dessus c'est la la
cause principale l'autre élément me
semble lié au fait que il y a besoin
sans doute de ce que j'ai qu'on dont on
a parlé tout à l'heure d'une réforme
fiscale sans
doute assez ambitieus qui permettent de
distinguer disons de fiscaliser tout un
ensemble de de dépenses qui ne sont
contributive euh et qui n'ont pas de
raison d'être dans le cadre du système
de sécurité sociale tel qu'il a été
conçu après la guerre dans dans une
condition dans des conditions
complètement opposées de démographie il
faut penser le lien qui a entre la
démographie la nature des services qui
apparaissent et puis la nature des du
financement donc notre financement
disons fondé sur une représentation
corporative en quelque sorte hein qui
pouvait tout à fait justifier après la
la guerre hein et qui a qui a très bien
marché dans des années de croissance me
semble être nécessairement à transformer
et dans la dans la persp dans dans ce
qu'on fait d'autres pays en quelque
sorte hein donc voilà voilà un peu ce
qui me semble important le public
productif innovation les les les
professeur d'université non ce que je
crois c'est
que le capital humain est crucial pour
euh la le monde moderne hein pour la
croissance l'économie de la connaissance
implique capital humain euh euh doit
devenir un facteur absolument
déterminant de la croissance or le mode
de comptabilité que nous avons qui reste
une comptabilité de flux je vous
rappelle elle a été conçue après la
guerre et elle a évolué que
lentement était conçu en effet pour
gérer la conjoncture c'est-à-dire la
demande globale autour d'un pb potentiel
qu'on considérait comme assuré et qui
fonction et qui fonctionnait tout seul
hein pendant toute cette phase de de
grande croissance après guerre
une comptabilité de la régulation
macroéconomique de la dépense or ce don
nous avons besoin c'est une croissance
soutenable et une croissance soutenable
implice une comptabilité patrimoniale
généralisée c'est-à-dire que le stock de
capital c'est à la fois un stock de
capital privé et public capital social
en fait il faudrait revenir à Adam Smith
la richesse des nations et et on a
besoin de vous avez une avancée de la
comptabilité qui se fait dans le cadre
de la Banque mondiale qui se fait dans
le cadre des nations- Unies mais les
grands organismes statistiques des
nations des États n'ont pas encore fait
cette avancée on a des comptes de
patrimoine mais il reste annexe nous et
on on les introduit pas justement dans
la logique de la croissance or nous
avons besoin besoin d'une comptabilité
sociale généralisée du capital et à ce
moment-là vous redonnez une très grande
importance à toutes les formes de
capital et y compris au capital que
j'appelle collectif euh et qui dans le
cadre d'une il faut il faut en quelque
sorte si vous voulez innover
profondément dans notre conception de la
croissance pour arriver à un concept de
soutenabilité qui soit opérationnel
voilà pourquoi je mets l'accent
évidemment beaucoup sur cette affaire de
recherche développement et d'éducation
supérieure merci infiniment monsieur le
professeur mes chers collègues nous
n'avons pas des viis nous n'avons pas
d'avis à admettre formellement mais je
pense que nous pouvons nous re quelques
applaudissements merci beaucoup Monsieur
le Professeur donc mes chers collègues
restez là puisque nous avons à
auditionner une future haute conseillère
madame Mathilde
Lemoine
pressenti
voilà
irir
voilà et bien je vous en prie prenez
place
voilà Dav
voilà donc je vais accélérer
alors mes chers collègues nous reprenons
si vous le voulez bien pour cette
seconde audition d'un membrre pressentis
du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques je ne vais pas redire tout le
contenu de mon introduction de tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire la base légale de
cette
désignation les fonctions du ha conseil
des des finances
publiques nous allons demander à Madame
Mathilde Lemoine de se présenter de nous
faire part de sa
vision du couple contradictoire
compétenence
indépendance comment être totalement
indépendant si l'on n'a pas une vision
concrète des rouages et du
fonctionnement du monde financier et si
l'on est compétent par cette
connaissance concrète demeuret-on
indépendant donc c'est c'est c'est c'est
évidemment une question tout à fait
fondamentale qu'évoquait par exemple
alain Milon tout à l'heure et qui vaut
pour toutes sortes d'instances et de et
de responsabilité et pas seulement dans
le monde économique et financier
et Madame l moine nous donnera sans
doute
aussi sa
vision de ce que doit faire le Haut
Conseil nous avons entendu
michelaglietta et lorsque je
l'interrogais sur les avis est-ce que le
Haut Conseil va créer sa
doctrine est-ce qu'il va se borner à
répondre à minima aux questions qui lui
sont posées quelle place va-t-il prendre
dans ce dans ce processus complexe et
euh par
ailleurs pensez-vous madame le mooine
que le Haut Conseil puisse substituer
ses appréciations à celles du
gouvernement sur le taux de croissance
et sur d'autres variables
macro-économiques pensez-vous que le
Haut
Conseil
puisse jouer un
rôle en matière de rapprochement des des
des des données des appréciations entre
l'Union européenne et la France
pensez-vous que le Haut Conseil doivent
développer des coopération avec les
organismes indépendants comparables des
autres
États-membres de la zone
euro
voilà quelques questions que vous allez
être amené sans doute à traiter dans
votre exposé
introductif je m'arrête là et je passe
la parole à madame anie David présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
merci monsieur le Président à mon tour
je ne vais pas répéter enfin réitérer
des propos de notre introduction de tout
à l'heure mais il est vrai que Madame le
mooine pourrait se sentir un peu malmené
si toutefois nous na nous nous n'avions
pas euh un minimum de correction donc je
vourais simplement vous rappeler euh et
bien que avec la commission des affaires
sociales d'ailleurs le rapporteur
général euh ainsi que bien sûr monsieur
Marc le rapporteur général des finances
vous posera quelques questions insister
sur le fait que à la commission des
affaires sociales il nous semble
important que la dimension des dépenses
sociales soit aussi bien prise en compte
dans ce Haut Conseil qui va bientôt être
nommé et don pour lequel vous êtes
pressenti madame comme comme membre
voilà simplement insister quand même sur
ces dépenses sociales qui nous semblent
très importantes à prendre en compte
dans l'ensemble dans l'ensemble de la
des prospective que vous êtes vous serez
amené à avoir dans le la globalité des
dépenses publiques mer merci alors je
passe la parole à Madame Mathilde
Lemoine
pour sa présentation introductive merci
monsieur le Président bonjour monsieur
le Président Madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs
généraux je vais commencer par mon
parcours rapidement et et ce que je fais
aujourd'hui j'ai commencé ma ma carrière
comme enseignant chercheur et mon mon
apprentissage de la théorie économique a
été sanctionné par un par un doctorat
en sciences économique le sujet était la
croissance des dépenses publiques
synthèse théorique et validation
empirique et ça m'a valu à l'époque des
remarques de mon directeur de thèse qui
m'a dit que c'était un sujet tout à fait
dépassé que je trouverais jamais
d'emploi donc j'étais absolument
passionné par la théorie des choix
publics et donc j'ai appris toute la
théorie des choix publics lors de mon
apprentissage de la théorie économique
et j'ai continué par un postdoctorat euh
en économie de la santé et j'ai continué
à travailler sur donc les questions de
choix public et de théorie économique
pendant un moment ensuite je me suis
spécialisée dans la macroéconomie
internationale que j'ai exercé dans euh
toujours à la Fondation nationale des
sciences politiques où j'ai commencé ma
carrière comme enseignant chercheur
ensuite à l'ofco j'ai travaillé avec
Jean-Paul fitousi puis dans différents
cabinets ministériels où j'étais en
charge de la macroéconomie
internationale de la mondialisation et
aussi de la fiscalité puisque je suis
revenue à matinon à mes premiers amours
de théorie des choix
publics donc c'est vrai que ma
spécialité est plutôt la connaissance de
la théorie économique et de la prévision
macro-économique internationale j'ai
réalisé un manuel sur ces théories de
commerce international et sur les
évolutions en matière théorique de
commerce
international et depuis 2006 je suis en
charge
de la direction des études économiques
de la banque
HSBC
France et ensuite depuis 2007 de la
stratégie marché de cette même banque où
pour laquelle je doit réaliser des
prévisions
macroéconomiques pour les pays de la
zone euro par participer à l'élaboration
de prévision de Chang et de taux mais
aussi réaliser des études et des
analyses structurelles pour améliorer la
compréhension des investisseurs
internationaux en matière d'évolution
macroéconomique et c'est vrai que depuis
2006 je suis dans un environnement privé
ce qui n'était pas le cas jusqu'à cette
date puisque j'ai été dans des
organismes public ou
parapubl et euh j'ai souhaité
euh bénéficier de cette expérience pour
justement améliorer
euh mon apprentissage euh de des marchés
financiers de leur impact sur mes
prévisions macro-économiques et il est
vrai que récemment on s'est rendu compte
que les modèles de prévision
macro-économique classiques de type euh
de ceux utilisés par le Trésor ou
d'autres organismes sous-estimaient euh
l'influence des évolutions financières
et je trouve intéressant de pouvoir par
ma meilleure appréhension des évolutions
financières essayer de de de de
progresser dans les liens entre économie
financière et économie réelle et je
prends un exemple récent qui me tient à
cœur c'est que on a vu que un certain
nombre de de d'investisseurs avaient
considéré que le risque d'éclatement de
la zone euro euh s'était accru et ça
s'était traduit par une prime de risque
systémique euh plus importante que celle
qu'on avait connu jusqu'à présent qui
euh a engendré un coût euh pour les pays
euh c'est-à-dire que les pays de la zone
euro par rapport aux autres pays du
monde euh avaiit un coût à supporter du
fait même de leur appartenance à la zone
euro et ce cette prime de risque
systémique n'est évidemment pas intégré
dans les modèles macro-économiques et
donc on ne voit pas le lien entre cette
interprétation ou cet avis des
investisseurs et les évolutions de
l'investissement des entreprises et à
contrario c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui je
considère que cette réduction de la
prime de risque systémique est
sous-estimée dans les modèles
macro-économiques comme elle avait été
sous-estimée à l'inverse et que
probablement on sous-estime
l'investissement aujourd'hui les
investissements le rebond modeste certes
mais le rebond d'un certain nombre
d'investissements en zone euro parce que
on a du mal à faire ce lien entre les
deux donc voilà de de façon assez rapide
les éléments de mon parcours mais
au-delà de mes compétences en matière de
prévision de mes compétences
statistiques que je trouve finalement
assez peu intéressante parce que ce que
je ce qui me semble important c'est
vraiment la connaissance de la théorie
économique et c'est ce à quoi j'ai
travaillé depuis le début de ma carrière
pour justement faire en sorte que les
évaluations statistiques soient les
meilleurs possibles et je ne crois pas
que la statistique en elle-même puisse
permettre d'améliorer la compréhension
des évolutions et améliorer la prévision
puisque de fait c'est l'input théorique
ou l'appréciation des interdépendances
entre les différentes variables qui
permet d'améliorer la qualité des
prévisions donc je pense que le la la
statistique et l'économétrie reste un
outil au service du d'une d'une d'une
d'une théorie
voilà alors en ce qui
concerne mon mon métier d'économiste mon
stat d'économiste et et mon indépendance
alors c'est vrai que c'est un sujet et
et je comprends tout à fait que ce soit
une
préoccupation en tant
qu'économiste je suis protégée par la
muraille de Chine c'est-à-dire
que la banque a mis en place comme les
banques les autres banques d'ailleurs
toute une série de
dispositifs afin que je ne sois pas
influencé dans le choix de mes sujets ni
dans le le le résultat de mes travaux
alors ça passe par des des des
dispositifs qui peuvent paraître
anecdotique comme le fait
d'être physiquement séparé des fonctions
de toutes les fonctions de marché de ne
pouvoir avoir de contact avec les
vendeurs
des des fonctions de marché sans qu'il y
ait un responsable de la compliance qui
suit cette discussion c'est c'est c'est
des choses qui je peux que je peux
développer bien évidemment en fonction
de vos questions mais qui sont
extrêmement contraignantes et dont la
réalité est vérifiée par
l'AMF puisque ce sont des règles de
place que les banques sont obligées de
respecter alors vous allez me dire il y
a la théorie le légal la pratique et
est-ce que la pratique est-ce que je me
sens vraiment libre de ce point de vuel
et est-ce que je me sens libre de mes
analyses et du choix de mes sujets sans
hésiter oui
et je crois que les prises de position
que j'ai prises notamment en matière
d'immobilier en matière de corrélation
entre le prix de l'essence et le prix du
pétrole euh en matière ne serait-ce que
de prévision macro-économique montre
qu'effectivement il m'est arrivé à de
nombreuses reprises d'avoir des
pressions extrêmement forte de la part
d'un certain nombre de de de responsable
d'entreprise
ou ou même quelquefois du gouvernement
puisque j'avait des prévisions
budgétaires qui étaient qui n'allaient
pas dans le sens du consensus par
exemple donc ensuite il est vrai hein
que il y a le dispositif réel c'est
inscrit dans le règlement intérieur de
la banque et c'est vérifié par la MF
c'est la muraille de Chine c'est le
respect donc de l'indépendance des
analyses et des sujets alors des
vis-à-vis des vis-à-vis des membres de
la banque vis-à-vis des clients
vis-à-vis des gouvernements tout est
spécifié et tout est fait pour que ce
soit respecté et ensuite il y a aussi
les faits et je crois que les faits je
tiens à disposition de votre assemblée
l'ensemble de mes travaux lesffit montre
qu'effectivement je n'ai pas hésité à à
prendre des
positions qui ont suscité des réactions
assez vives de la part des euh des
responsables d'entreprise qui par
ailleurs pouvait être client de la
banque et dans ce cas-là la muraille de
Chine a fonctionné puisque la banque à
aucun moment ne m'a demandé de modifier
ou d'infléchir ou de ne pas publier ou
de retirer de la publication mes
analyses donc je je témoigne que c'est
aussi une réalité et pas simplement des
règles une autre question pourrait se
poser de mon point de vue c'est celle
qui est liée à à ma détention éventuelle
d'information
c'est-à-dire que le fait d'appartenir
éventuellement au Conseil
pourrait me permettre d'avoir des
informations avant qu'ell soi publique
et là encore une fois je pense que on
peut se référer assez facilement au
règlement général de l'AMF qui dit
que donc l'économiste en l'occurrence
d'autres métiers mais c'est ce qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui l'économiste que
je suis ne peut utiliser ces
informations bien évidemment ni les
communiqués sinon je tombe tout
simplement sous le coup du règlement
général de l'AMF et ça fait l'objet ça
peut faire l'objet d'une
d'une poursuite juridique donc je crois
que enfin je crois qu'il y a pas
grand-chose d'autre à ajouter et il me
semble que ça signifie que si je publie
puisque je travaille sur les questions
de la zone euro et sur la zone euro dans
son ensemble y compris la France bien
évidemment cela signifie dans la
pratique que je ne pourrais pas publier
quoi que ce soit sur les évolutions
conjoncturelles de la zone euro y
compris budgétaire avant que l'ensemble
des informations soi
publiqu alors en ce qui concerne et
c'était le le le troisème objet de de de
de vos questions en ce qui concerne le
rôle du Haut Conseil alors j'ai entendu
la fin de l'audition de Michel Aglietta
et c'est vrai que j'ai le sentiment
après l'avoir entendu d'être finalement
beaucoup moins ambitieuse et peut-être
c'est un tort mais en tout cas c'est ma
conception des choses ce qui me semble
aujourd'hui important c'est de sortir de
la cristallisation autour du taux de
croissance et que je crois que une des
vertus et une des missions du Haut
conseil serait de mieux expliquer et de
mieux mettre en lumière les hypothèses
sous-jacentes au taux de
croissance pour pour
que le Parlement et le gouvernement mais
en l'occurrence le Parlement est une
meilleure appréciation justement des
conditions de réalisation de cette
prévision de croissance et je prends un
certain nombre d'exemples par exemple
sur l'hypothèse conventionnelle du taux
de change est-ce que ça a un sens ou pas
sur encore une fois le fait que dans les
modèles
macro-économiques on a une une ces
modèles macroéconomique fonctionne assez
bien à court terme mais que à moyen
terme tous toutes les variables vont
vers leur moyenne de longue période donc
est-ce que ça a un sens quand on fait
des prévisions à
2017 de voir que bah on revient à la
moyenne de longue période est-ce que
est-ce quce que est-ce qu'il y a pas
d'autres modèles est-ce que on peut pas
introduire des variantes et donc dans ce
cas-là qu'est-ce que ça signifie en
matière de de taux de croissance si on
introduit des variantes ça veut dire
qu'on va caler le modèle différemment
donc dans ce
cas-là
quelles sont les conséquences en matière
d'appréciation des évolutions de
croissance je crois qu'il y a il y
a il y a vraiment à progresser en la
matière et je trouve que aujourd'hui
depuis plusieurs années
désormais il a été demandé à l'INC de
publier le plus tôt possible des
premières estimations des taux de
croissance et de fait on se focalise et
le débat public se focalise pour savoir
à 0 point ou 02 points près ce que va
être ce taux de croissance alors que par
exemple pour 2013 on ne le connaîtra
qu'en février
2014 en revanche de bien avoir en tête
les hypothèses sur lesquelles sont basé
ce taux de croissance me paraît
extrêmement utile et là le conseil de
mon point de vue pourrait émettre des
avis sur justement le fait que certaines
hypothèses ne sont pas du tout
consensuelles et que certaines
hypothèses mériteraient un débat qui
pourrait éclairer justement la
probabilité de survenance du taux de
croissance donc ça c'est quelque chose
auquel je tiens et c'est pour ça que je
disais que finalement je suis moins
ambitieuse c'est que je pense que de ce
point de vue-là le Haut Conseil pourrait
apporter quelque chose alors même chose
sur l'évaluation du PIB potentiel parce
que les conséquences de ces évaluations
sont extrêmement lourdes et en même
temps il revient à l'assemblée de
décider de quel est le niveau potentiel
elle souhaite introduire dans les lois
de finance quel est le le taux de
croissance qu'elle souhaite introduire
dans dans la loi de finance c'est pas au
conseil de décider et je pense que le
Haut Conseil aura d'autant plus
d'influence qu'il est capable d'étayer
son
avis encore une fois en insistant sur
les hypothèces sous-jacente et en ce qui
concerne le PIB potentiel c'est
fondamental parce que on est dans une
situation de crise qui fait que on est
incapable aujourd'hui d'évaluer quel est
l'impact durable
de la crise sur le PIB potentiel
c'est-à-dire est-ce que les faillites
d'entreprise vont détruire du stock de
capital et durablement baisser le pb
potentiel ou est-ce que finalement la
politique du gouvernement va permettre
de faire en sorte que d'autres
entreprises vont naître et compenser
cette destruction de soc de
capital donc on voit bien que là de fait
il y a une appréciation politique de
l'efficacité des politiques économiques
qui sont mis en œuvre et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans le calcul du PIB
potentiel du point de vue du
gouvernement et il me semble que le Haut
conseil c'est pas son son son son rôle
en tout cas de donner un jugement
définitif pour savoir si effectivement
la destruction de capital liée à la
crise va être compensée ou non par des
nouvelles créations d'entreprises parce
que par définition c'est de la prévision
donc il le sait pas plus en revanche il
peut dire voilà la probabilité lors des
crises précédentes voilà théoriquement
ce qui nous semble une méthode
statistique qui permet d'évaluer tout
jugement politique alors on va prendre
des filtres statistiques mais de fait il
y a aucun une input et ça ça ne permet
pas d'introduire l'apport de la théorie
économique ou on prend la théorie
économique pour évaluer le PIP potentiel
grâce à une fonction de production et
dans ce cas-là ça nécessite une
interprétation des
évolutions ou de l'impact des politiques
économiques qui sont menées et le Haut
Conseil peut émettre un avis sur la
probabilité de surveignance de de de de
de l'impact de ces politiques
économiques même chose pour vous parliez
de l'importance des dépenses
social le meilleur exemple aussi pour ce
calcul du P potentiel c'est l'impact de
des réformes des retraites ou de ce qui
est fait en matière de réformes des
retraites de fait la différence
d'appréciation du PIB potentiel entre la
Commission et le gouvernement vient
aussi du fait de l'introduction de la de
l'impact de la réforme des retraites
dans le calcul du PIB potentiel donc là
il me semble que le Haut Conseil doit
euh d'abord mettre en lumière cette
différence de façon beaucoup plus
précise et rigoureuse que ce qui'est
fait jusqu'à présent et ensuite
peut-être de de faire un certain nombre
de variantes pour dire voilà si on
évalue l'impact des retraites de telle
façon voilà ce que ça implique sur le ça
implique sur le PIP potentiel voilà ce
que ça implique sur le déficit
structurel et donc voilà les
conséquences que ça peut avoir sur les
la trajectoire de moyen terme
euh voilà ce qui me semble moi important
et et voilà ce qui me ce qui d'ailleurs
me préoccupe aujourd'hui avant même de
de de de de réfléchir à à aux réponses à
à vos questions monsieur madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président c'est
vraiment de
d'améliorer la compréhension des
prévisions et surtout qu'il ait plus de
décision en conscience sur les
hypothèses retenues pour l'ensemble des
variables alors je sais que il y a aussi
beaucoup de questions
sur com comment je vois les choses et et
là c'est vrai que je suis un peu
perturbée par rapport à ces questions
parce que dans ce que j'ai vu le Haut
Conseil aura pour le seul cas où la
trajectoire
s'écarterait de la trajectoire de moyen
terme pourrait motiver éventuellement
en donnant des des des moyens de
parvenir à à à à réduire cet écart de
trajectoire mais il me semble encore une
fois que la mission principale du Haut
conseil c'est vraiment eu égard à ce qui
ce qui a été voté c'est de dire voilà
quelle est aujourd'hui comp tenu de la
connaissance théorique économétrique et
statistique dont on dispose quelle est
la probabilité que les prévisions le
calcul du PIP potentiel soit amélioré ou
pas et quelle est l'interprétation
ensuite qui peut être faite de de de de
ces calculs donc voilà rapidement mes
réponses à aux trois points et bien
évidemment je suis à votre disposition
pour pour merci infiniment madame CIS
pouvoir souligner le caractère
extrêmement complémentaire des deux
prestations que nous avons entendu ce
matin et je passe aussitôt la parole à
Messieurs les rapporteurs généraux
commençant par François Marc oui merci
monsieur le Président et merci Madame le
moine de nous avoir déjà éclairé en
préambule et d'avoir déjà répondu à
certaines des questions que je m' prêé
pour ma part à poser euh nous avons eu
l'occasion déjà depuis de de nombreuses
années de d'apprécier vos contribution
euh tant écrite que vos participations
des débats ici au Sénat ou dans
différentes instances et donc je me
plais à souligner comme j'ai fait
précédemment que le la préconisation du
du Sénat vous désignez comme celle de
euh michelaglietta tout à l'heure me
paraissêtre de bonnes préconisations et
nous serons très heureux de pouvoir
siéger au sein de ce Haut conseil dont
on a du mal à anticiper le le mode réel
de fonctionnement et l'étendu des des
prérogatives et et euh des appréciations
qu'il va pouvoir porter ces raison pour
laquelle je vais peut-être vous demander
des
d'éclairer nos collègues sur trois ou
quatre points quant à votre propre
conception de ce que sera le rôle du
conseil surtout de votre la perception
que vous avez aujourd'hui de euh du
fonctionnement de ce conseil tout
d'abord en ce qui concerne
l'articulation des fonctions de membres
et et d'économistes euh on on sait que
c'est un sujet délicat lorsque il y a
communication d'avis euh parce que le
Haut Conseil est amené à a donné des
avis qui sont rendus publics qui sont
argumentés et les membres du Haut
Conseil peuvent vouloir répondre à des
questions qu' leur sont posées à titre
personnel euh sur
euh les avis qui ont été donc donné or
on sait et je prend je prends l'exemple
du comité de politique monétaire de de
la Banque centrale américaine lorsqueun
de ses membres s'exprime euh et donne un
avis personnel qui est parfois un peu
contradictoire avec euh la vie
généralement publié euh ça peut
entraîner des du ressac dans euh euh les
évolutions financières et boursières euh
donc comment concevez-vous votre votre
rôle cette façon de coordonner les deux
vous êtes vous serez membre d'un Haut
Conseil qui émet un avis collectif qui
est publié qui est officiel et puis dans
le même temps vous restez économiste et
vous avez donc parfois des perceptions
des points de vuees euh euh qui peuvent
différer et on sait d'ailleurs vous
l'avez montré récemment que vous ne
craignez pas de vous affranchir de la
vie d'un consensus et et de donner votre
sentiment d'une façon tout à fait
personnel donc comment envisagez-vous de
de continuer à à faire fonctionner tout
cela s'agissant des méthodes de travail
je voulais avoir votre éclairage sur sur
trois points tout d'abord premier point
c'est sur euh la trajectoire elle-même
lorsque il pourrait apparaître que la
trajectoire euh de PIB potentiel qui est
précisée par le la loi de programmation
des finances publiques n'est plus
crédible ça pourrait se produire est-ce
que vous pensez que le Haut Conseil
pourrait aller jusqu'à se doter de
euh d'une autre trajectoire de PIB
potentiel c'est-à-dire de bah de
corriger la copie hein tout simplement
et et et de refaire le travail avec une
autre trajectoire est-ce que ça peut
aller jusque là dans votre
le la mission qui pourrait être confiée
deuxème question sur ces ces sujets et
ce mode de
fonctionnement quel est votre sentiment
sur l'appréciation apporté sur ce que
sont les circonstances exceptionnelles
qui permettrai de s'écarter
provisoirement de la trajectoire est-ce
que vous avez
une une grande ouverture d'esprit par
rapport à à ces circonstances
exceptionnelles qui peuvent générer de
la la souplesse ou au contraire est-ce
que c'est une perception qui doit être
nécessairement
réductrice sur ce champ d'investigation
et enfin dernière question toujours sous
cet angle c'est celle me semble-t-il
important de la responsabilité du Haut
Conseil parce que
euh il peut très bien y avoir une
censure des lois financières euh par le
le Conseil constitutionnel pour un motif
d'insincérité sur la base de ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel aura pu tirer
comme enseignement de l'avis du Haut
Conseil et donc on pourrait nous dire
ben il y a un sincérité parce que c'est
en trop forte contradiction avec la vie
du Haut Conseil et dans ces conditions
il pourrait y avoir censure donc ça
entraîne tout de
même questionnement sur la
responsabilité est-ce que ça conduit à à
nécessaire prudence du au Conseil est-ce
que on doit être vigilant
à rester quelque part part
dans une
appréciation assez prudente et assi
éviter qu'il y ait de la casse si je me
permet d'expression dans la procédure de
de fin d'examen des lois budgétaires et
et de consultation du Conseil
constitutionnel voilà donc quelques
éléments de questionnement peut-être sur
lesquels vous pourriez nous éclairer sur
votre propre perception des
choses merci beaucoup monsieurvier
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales merci monsieur le
Président Madame et chers collègues
madame je vous ai écouté avec la plus
grande et extrême attention et je
partage bien évidemment les
appréciations qui sont celles de mon
collègue François Marc sur la
perspective de votre nomination au
conseil des finan publique alors je
voudrais à cet instant après la madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales il y a quelques
instants rappeler l'importance
déterminante des dépenses de protection
sociale dans l'évolution des dépenses
publiques et dans dans la situation
financière globale des comptes publics
je le illustrerai à travers un seul
chiffre hein sur l'exercice 2011
dépenses de prestation sociale c'est
plus de 50 % de l'ensemble des dépenses
des administrations publiques donc en
valeur absolue 557 milliards d'euros je
voudrais rappeler également l'importance
des pouvoirs attribués au Haut Conseil
des finances publiques dans la sphère
sociale par la loi organique avec avec
les interventions donc en amont des
PLFSS éventuellement des lois
rectificatives et avec la possibilité de
se prononcer sur les objectifs
pluriannuels de dépenses des régimes
obligatoires de base de sécurité sociale
et sur l'évolution pluri-annuel de
landendame donc ce sont pas des éléments
négligeables ou de faible importance
pour nous alors si euh je peux bon
peut-être résumer deux questions d'ordre
général madame comment définiriez-vous
la spécificité des finances sociales au
sein des finances publiques cette
éventuelle spécificité pourra-t-elle
selon vous être prise en compte dans le
cadre des travaux du Haut Conseil et
deuxième question également d'ordre
général le redressement nécessaire des
comptes publics vous paraît-il dans le
contexte économique actuel compatible
avec le maintien d'un système de
protection sociale de qualité et puis
une question plus spécifique au domaine
social le comité d'alerte de l'assurance
maladie qui est placé auprès de la
commission des comptes de la Sécurité
sociale est chargé de rendre un avis
alors je cite les termes exacts dans
lequel il contrôle les éléments ayant
permis l'élaboration de l'objectif
national de dépenses d'assurance maladie
envisagé pour l'année à venir dans le
cadre donc du
PLFSS ce comité est également chargé de
détecter d'éventuels dépassements en
cours d'exercice compte tenu des
attributions relativement proches ENF à
mon sens du Haut Conseil et et du comité
n'existe-t-il pas un risque que ce
dernier soit Infiné absorbé par le Haut
Conseil vous paraît-il opportun
d'auditionner les représentants du
comité dans le cadre des travaux du Haut
Conseil comme le permet d'ailleurs
l'article 18 de la loi organique je vous
remercie alors madame l'économiste en
chef voudriez-vous répondre aux
rapporteurs
généraux merci de votre confiance aussi
de nombreuses questions alors très
difficiles monsieur le sénateur Marc sur
l'articulation en tant que économiste et
membres euh effectivement
euh le fait éventuellement d'appartenir
au Conseil donnera sans aucun doute une
résonance particulière aux propos que je
pourrais tenir sur les finances
publiques au-delà de la France mais même
sur les finances publiques de la zone
euro je pense que ça c'est absolument
incontestable et
donc c'est pour c'est pour cela qu'il me
semble que la prudence évidemment en la
matière et sera
deise mais au-delà de ça la question qui
est posée c'est aussi ma liberté en tant
qu'économiste
et ma liberté de publication pour la
banque ce qui reste mon
travail
principal en matière ution des
prévisions et de finances
publiques là je crois pas que ce soit
incompatible et encore une
fois je suis désolé de pas avoir de
répones définitive mais je pense que
c'est un c'est un un haut conseil qui va
se mettre en place petit à petit mais il
me semble que la nature de ce que je
publie et certes conjoncturelle je fais
des prévisions toutes les semaines tous
les mois tous les trimestres tous les
ans pluriannuels je fais ça tout le
temps et ce qui ressort malgré tout
c'est les analyses sous-jacentes à ces
prévisions je ne crois pas être en
situation d'être
totalement dissidente par rapport à un
avis du Haut
Conseil alors peut-être que c'est parce
que j'ai une conception du Haut Conseil
qui est plus basée sur la mise en
perspective des analyses des hypothèses
sous-jacentes aux prévisions et que je
n'oublie pas qu'au final c'est le
Parlement qui
décide et donc je crois pas que il ait
justement matière à publication
dissidente ensuite s'il y a un
écart si le le le le ha conseil publie
un avis pour dire que par exemple la
prévision de croissance lui
semble cohérente avec un certain nombre
d'hypothèses et ou pas
d'ailleurs dans mes publications il y
aura il y aura évidemment un taux de
croissance qui sera publié
mais je crois pas que ce
soit je crois pas que ce soit dissident
en la matière alors encore une fois je
désolé mais je je j'ai pas de réponse
définitive j'en ai sur un certain nombre
de points sur celui-ci
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
je suis extrêmement consciente du fait
que l'appartenance éventuelle à ce Haut
Conseil créera une caisse de résonance
particulière à tout ce que je pourrais
dire en la matière ou tout ce que je
pourrais écrire en la matière et donc ça
nécessitera de ma part de la prudence ce
qui ne voudra pas dire que je penseraiis
comme l'ensemble collégial du Haut
Conseil en ce qui concerne les méthodes
de travail sur le la trajectoire du PIB
potentiel je crois pas que ce soit le la
mission du Haut Conseil de refaire la
trajectoire du du du PIB toute la
trajectoire
euh oui en tout cas moi voilà après je
je ce que je crois euh en revanche que
le le le le Haut Conseil encore une fois
dise euh ou mettre l'accent sur euh des
hypothèses sous-jacentes au calcul
actuel euh par exemple que le Haut
Conseil puisse demander au gouvernement
euh comment il calcule euh la la la
productivité globale des facteurs
aujourd'hui et quelle est son
appréciation euh enfin ou quelles sont
les politiques économiques qui sont
considérées pour sortir une hypothèse
supérieure à celle de la commission par
exemple ça ça me semble être son rôle et
ensuite
que il en déduisent parce que euh le le
le le la question n'est pas assez
où les réponses ne sont pas assez
articulées ou argumentées que
effectivement le le le le le PIP
potentiel tel qu'il est calculé n'est
pas
prudent voilà c'est c'est en tout cas
moi la façon dont je dont je vois les
choses et ensuite que il
puisse
proposer une un calcul plus prudent ou
moins prudent en l'occurrence voilà une
fourchette on va dire
oui
mais dans ce sens il ne définira pas la
trajectoire du PIP potentiel puisque ça
reviendra au Parlement et enfin au
gouvernement et au Parlement qui
décidera ou non de de de de
d'intégrer cette prudence de calcul ou
non hein donc c'est pour ça que je vous
dis je enfin c'est pas ma conception
dans le sens où je pense pas que ce soit
le Haut Conseil et la d'abord je pense
pas que le Haut Conseil puisse avoir la
vérité en la
matière en revanche ce que je crois
c'est que le Haut Conseil
peut avoir enfin aura les compétences
techniques pour
éclairer l'Assemblée le gouvernement
voilà sur les méthodes de calcul et
encore une fois sur l'appréciation de
l'impact des politiques économique c'est
là où il peut y avoir discussion hein
évidemment et c'est là où le le niveau
de potentiel le niveau de PIP potentiel
ensuite va avoir une importance
considérable pour la définition du solde
structurel mais au-delà de ça
on voit bien qu'à je dirais à tous les
étages à toutes les étapes le débat est
possible et euh quand on passera du PIP
potentiel au calcul du déficit
structurel là aussi il y a des
conventions qui sont retenu il y a des
élasticités qui sont proposées par
l'OCDE est-ce que
vraiment tout le monde a conscience de
des sous-jacents à ces à ces conventions
est-ce que euh
est-ce que c'est en connaissance de
cause
que que ces trajectoires ou c'est ces
chemins de moyen terme de déficit
structurel sont décidés il me semble
qu'en la matière le conseil peut
apporter beaucoup et donc et donc
répondre à à sa mission et aussi à au
fait enfin oui à à son objectif
finalement européen qui est d'avoir une
meilleure
harmonisation des procéd en matière de
prévision macro-économique et
d'évaluation du P potentiel et du
déficit structurel parce que au final
c'est ça donc je crois pas que ce soit
enfin à aucun moment en tout cas j'ai
considéré que sa mission puisse être de
dire oui non en revanche
que son qui donne un avis et pour moi
l'important sera encore une fois sa
capacité à l'éteayer être convaincant et
de pour faire en sorte que au final il y
a une il a une cohérence dans
l'établissement des trajectoires de
moyen terme en zone euro et que ensuite
la Commission puisse proposer au Conseil
européen
d'éventuellement changer ou non cette
trajectoire mais là c'est pas le rôle du
Haut Conseil il me semble il me semble
que là aussi ça revient au chefs d'État
et de
gouvernement parce que aujourd'hui un
des problèmes et je crois qu'il faut
enfin cas pour ma part je veux pas
oublier le le contexte européen qui est
important qui me semble très important
c'est que aujourd'hui de fait on voit
bien qu'il y a des méthodes de calcul
qui sont pas
harmonisées je pense pas que l'objectif
final doiv être l'harmonisation
puisqueencore une fois chaque
gouvernement peut avoir une appréciation
différente d'un certain nombre de
facteurs et ce qui est important c'est
que ces appréciations soient sur la
table et qu'ensuite les les les les les
chefs d'État de gouvernement qui
décideront éventuellement d'un
changement de trajectire ire au niveau
européen puisse avoir l'ensemble de ces
éléments sur la table de façon simple et
que la décision politique puisse être
facile je pense que le rôle le rôle du
Haut Conseil est celui-ci et que il
faudrait pas non plus qu'il tombe dans
un
travers
de d'expert qui sait mieux ce qu'il faut
faire enfin en tout
cas pour ma part c'est c'est c'est
quelque
chose auquel je feris très très
attention euh donc ça c'était pour pour
la deuxième question alors sur les
circonstances exceptionnelles là je vais
être beaucoup plus euh encore une fois
plus modeste que Michel Aglietta et dans
un premier temps j'aurais tendance à me
à me référer à à ce qui avait été décrit
dans le cadre du Pacte budgétaire
euh voilà parce qu'il me semble que que
que ça peut être dans une première base
de discussion et
ensuite la question fondamentale qui est
posée qui a été décidée euh euh par les
assemblées euh et euh par euh les les
les gouvernements européens euh c'est
d'améliorer euh la soutenabilité des
finances publiques donc ensuite
euh peut-être de de de de éventuellement
la pratique fera réfléchir à euh quelles
peuvent être les les circonstances
exceptionnelles qui euh ne s'opposent
pas à cet objectif qui est encore une
fois un objectif de moyen terme qui est
la soutenabilité des finances publiques
euh sachant que j'ai une définition très
euh économique de la soutenabilité des
finances publiques et pas du tout euh
conjoncturelle et et et courttermiste
hein et donc c'est euh c'est euh à moyen
terme de de d'avoir un taux de
croissance nominale qui est euh qui est
supérieur au taux d'intérêt nominal hein
euh donc ensuite les modalités d'y
parvenir
euh peuvent peuvent être euh
multiples la responsabilité du ha
conseil elle est évidemment extrêmement
lourde et
et et invite à la prudence je dirais
c'est la même chose pour l'articulation
économiste membre euh je crois
que pour éviter que le Haut
Conseil est une responsabilité qui ne
soit pas la sienne il me semble que là
aussi
euh il est très très important
euh
d'éclairer les les les les
les les modalités de de de de de la vie
en fait les ce que le Haut Conseil
retiendrait
pour calculer par exemple
statistiquement sans aucun jugement sans
aucun apport théorique mais si on
prenait juste un filtre statistique de
de base et cetera voilà ce que ça
donnerait par exemple et donc est-ce
qu'on est loin de la prévision ou du
calcul du PIB potentiel ou pas ENF je
pense que je pense que là aussi il y a
quand même une
façon
extrêmement prudente de présenter les
choses sans que la prudence veuille
dire je dirais une
une enfin sans que la prudence invite le
Haut Conseil à atténuer un peu ce qu'il
voudrait dire je crois que la prudence
pour moi elle est pas là du tout en
revanche je suis consciente de l'impact
mais la prudence c'est vraiment encore
une fois de ne pas donner le sentiment
qu'il y a un calcul vrai un résultat
vrai et que le reste est insincère hein
parce que on sait tous tous ici que
c'est pas le cas donc je crois que c'est
très important que le Haut Conseil tombe
pas dans euh se travers et je je je je
suis sûr que il ne le fera pas et de
fait je crois pas que la la la
responsabilité du Haut Conseil
puisse permettre euh à elle seule euh de
de de de juger de l'insincérité de de
chiffres proposés
hein manière c'est au Conseil
constitutionnel que reviendrait
éventuellement cette décision sur la
base des travaux du Haut Conseil
oui mais mais encore une fois le le
le encore une fois le le le le fait de
pouvoir mettre en exerg et de façon
simple et compréhensible par tout le
monde les hypothèses sous-jacentes au
calcul fait
que soit effectivement ces hypothèses
euh disons on va dire sont pas
consensuels et dans ce cas-là rien
empêche le Parlement ou de de de de
demander des explications
supplémentaires au gouvernement mais
vous voyez je je pense pas que ce
soit je pense pas que que que que
l'inincérité puisse être déduite des
seuls avis du Haut
Conseil alors euh j'ai pas fin par
monsur le rapporteur Domini il y avait
un certain nombre de questions sur
dépenses sociales voilà
euh alors sur les la spécificité la
spécificité des dépenses sociales
effectivement une des une des
spécificités c'est qu'elles sont souvent
conjoncturelles et donc de fait on voit
bien la difficulté
de l'appréciation de l'évolution des
dépenses sociales eu égard au chemin
structurel de moyen terme
donc ça pour moi c'est c'est la SP la
spécificité des finances sociales et
donc ça
rend ça rend l'appréciation
structurelle difficile pas impossible
mais mais mais plus mais plus
difficile sur le le le redressement des
comptes publics avec le maintien d'un
système de qualité
oui je saurais pas répondre autre chose
il y a plusieurs raisons euh alors
j'avais j'avais montré quand j'avais
fait mon mon postdoctorat j'ai publié un
certain nombre de travaux sur les la
croissance des dépenses de santé et donc
j'avais montré euh que effectivement la
la croissance des dépenses de santé pour
enfin était euh était lié à à
l'amélioration du niveau de
développement d'un pays et que c'était
absolument pas un problème en la matière
que en revanche la question était le le
le financement hein de de ces dépenses
de santé estce que vous savez euh euh
évidemment et j'ai un modèle j'avais
j'avais réalisé un modèle économétrique
qui montrait que un des moyens de
limiter justement la croissance des
dépenses de santé c'était de réintégrer
les cotisations sociales dans le revenu
imposable et donc ça fonctionnait très
très bien ça ça ça ça engendrait un
ralentissement des de la croissance des
dépenses de santé puisque dans ce cas
l'économiste que j'étais considérait que
les cotisations sociales étaient comme
une forme d'assurance et donc devait
être soumise à l'impôt sur le revenu
donc voilà par exemple une une une
proposition assez iconoclaste à l'époque
qu'il reste je
crois et qui voilà et qui et qui
montrait que effectivement on peut on
peut il y a des propositions de la part
des économistes pour limiter justement
la croissence des dépenses de santé sans
que ça ça ça ça s'oppose tout de suite à
à la question de l'efficacité alors
ensuite et ça je vais pas aller sur
votre terrain monsieur le rapporteur
général il est évident que il y a des
politiques de santé plus spécifique et
plus micro-économique sur la
qualité sur la qualité et l'amélioration
de du financement versus qualité mais
sur l'aspect macroéconomique que je
connais mieux etvec mon domaine voilà
une des propositions et l'autre
proposition c'était que le la la le
Parlement décide d'un niveau de
redistribution et que ce soit ce niveau
de redistribution qui soit financé par
le système d'impôts et cotisation
sociale mais ça pose tous les problèmes
que vous connaissez très très bien qui
sont donc ça veut dire que le reste sera
financé par des assurances privées et
dans ce cas-là il y a tous les débats
sur les conséquences que ça peut avoir
sur le hasard moral la séleaction
adverse enfin toutes les questions
assurencielles voilà mais donc donc oui
oui double oui à votre à votre question
et je pense je pense queon n' pas
exploré tout parce que voilà c'est c'est
c'est des des des des sujets qui sont
complexes et et qui qui nécessite
justement des travaux
approfondis
mais en matière de de croissance
là de d'appréhender les évolutions de la
croissance des des dépenses sociales euh
il est vrai que en tant conjoncturiste
euh on j'ai établi un certain nombre de
modèles euh qui qui permettent d'avoir
une appréciation de cette évolution
alors le comité d'alerte et et je crois
que ce serait important de de
l'auditionner parce que évidemment il
est très en amont euh et et donc à ce
titre euh effectivement il il permet de
de de assez rapidement de constater une
une déviation de l'évolution de longâ
par rapport au au aux prévisions
mais là aussi l'interprétation est
importante et je crois que si ça ne fera
pas doublon par rapport à à la mission
du Haut Conseil
euh je crois
que le Haut Conseil devra quand même
rester
euh sensible à
l'évolution
générale macroéconomique
des dépenses sociales et donc de fait
avoir en tête et c'est ça va être là la
difficulté l'aspect conjoncturel versus
l'aspect
structurel
alors c'était pardon
c'était la
différence les questions sociales qui
sont tr lié à la conjoncture alors je je
je ferai pas cette distinction enfin
aussi euh aussi euh
euh aussi brutal je dirais euh parce que
euh il y a un enfin il y a un aspect
conjoncturel dans l'évolution des
retraites on peut voir aussi euh qui est
lié au euh
euh aux évolutions du chômage euh donc
aux
évolutions des cotisations enfin du
rendement des cotisations retraite
euh on le voit bien avec les aspects
complémentaires arg Carco hein c'est un
débat qui est assez assez vif euh et de
fait c'est pour ça que je je disais que
au-delà des des aspects microéconomiques
la spécificité des dépenses sociales
c'est une difficulté en encore plus
grande de distinguer les aspects
structurels des aspects conjoncturels et
je crois pas que euh on puisse dire que
les dépenses de sécurité sociale soient
conjoncturell et les dépenses de
retraite soient structurelles il me
semble que
euh par définition enfin on le sait bien
que la la santé est un élément important
de la croissance potentiel euh et
que le capital humain euh au-delà de la
formation euh le le le euh est un
élément important de la croissance
potentielle et que alors que les
éléments de retraite euh il peut y avoir
des aspects conjoncturels mais il y a
pas de justification à un déficit
structurel des retraites par exemple
enfin voilà donc je crois que il faut
pas considérer que l'ensemble des
dépenses de de sécurité so sociale soit
des dépenses conjoncturel euh en
revanche améliorer
l'efficacité comme je le disais essayer
de diminuer le tendentiel de croissance
sachant qu'il y a des fondamentaux
sous-jacents qui l'expliquent et le
justifi théoriquement euh le poids sur
le coût du travail enfin toutes toutes
ces questions évidemment sont sur la
table et et et de nombreuses
propositions ont été faites pour pour
améliorer
l'efficacité
mais il faut pas il faut pas en déduire
que l'ensemble des dépenses de sécurité
social sont des dépenses
conjoncturelles alors merci beaucoup y y
a-t-il des questions parmi les membres
de nos
commissions non vous ne semblez pas
même monsieur Hervé s'interroge non pas
de question particulière bon et bien je
crois que nous
ah ah Monsieur gaillard pardon vous me
cachiez monsieur gaillard une question
oui peut-être a-t-il déjà été répondu
dans par l'un les deux orateurs en tout
cas au moins un il une chose que j'ai
absolument pas compris c'est quelle
liberté de
publication vous avez en tant
qu'économiste dès lors que vous
appartenez à cette haute instance euh y
y a-t-il des des règles très
précises
il est prévu lors de la première réunion
du Haut Conseil qui est une une un
règlement intérieur donc de ce fait pour
l'instant sur ce point-là je peux pas
vous répondre en tout cas pour ma part
ce que je sais c'est
que mon appartenance éventuelle au au
Conseil
euh ne m' ne m'empêchera pas de publier
sur la conjoncture de la zone euro y
compris
française je peux pas vous répondre
autre chose parce que de fait c'est
c'est c'est c'est mon métier et c'est
parce que je fais des prévisions et que
je suis à même de de de publier sur ces
questions
que votre assemblée m'a proposé
éventuellement de rejoindre le conseil
donc là j'ai une réponse j'ai une
réponse claire c'est que je je je
continuerai depis oublié sur la les
questions de la zone euro et de la
France
ensuite mon appréciation personnelle
fait que comp tenu de la caisse de
résonance que ça peut
générer une certaine prudence dans dans
les termes dans la façon de de de de
présenter les choses me semble me semble
légitime mais ça ne m'empêchera pas de
de décrire le résultat de mes analyses
voilà vous nous dites que vous
observerez une prudence toute
particulière ce qui fera effectivement
que l'on scrutera avec d'autant plus
d'attention les quelques mots ou
quelques appréciations quelques
tendances qui ressortiront de vos
commentaires et je crois mes chers
collègues effectivement que nous nous
nous devons bien nous nous nous résoudre
à
vivre dans le monde tel qu' est qui est
un monde ouvert qui est un monde où des
informations circulent et que le rôle du
Haut Conseil qui est une collégialité
qui n'émettra d'avis qu'en tant que
collégialité n'est-ce pas et c'est bien
d'intégrer des écoles de pensée et
d'être un lieu de de de liberté
d'esprit en même temps dès lors qu'il
s'agit de porter un jugement sur des
prévisions mieux vaut savoir comment on
fait les prévisions et donc euh euh
c'est ce qui dans la complémentarité des
des des origines des tempéraments des
modes d'expression devrait permettre à
ce conseil de de de vivre de manière
tout à fait authentique et de prendre
euh toute sa fonction euh peut-être un
mot de de de de conclusion si vous le
voulez bien s'il n'y a pas d'autres
interventions souvent nous tournons au
Parlement autour de cette question
quelle place pour les organes
d'expertise pour les collèges
indépendants les autorités
administratives indépendants est-ce le
gouvernement des experts
et Mathilde Lemoine me semble avoir à
juste titre prêté un soin tout
particulier à bien nous dire comment
elle voit l'articulation des choses
c'est le législateur qui décide y
compris et nous n en avons pas encore
assez conscience le PIB potentiel quand
est-ce qu'on décide du PIB potentiel en
vente la loi de programmation des
finances publiques si nous
substituons une trajectoire à une autre
et nous modifions le PIB potentiel et et
et c'est notre responsabilité alors le
législateur sous la 5e République c'est
à la fois le gouvernement et le
Parlement bien sûr mais l'instance
expertale est là pour éclairer
objectiver et il il y a beaucoup à faire
en ce domaine je crois que les membres
du Haut Conseil au-delà de leur
diversité sont tous des pédagogues et
doivent être des communicants et
peut-être il y a-t-il un singulier
paradoxe à ce que cette audition
publicque n'est attiré aucun
journaliste parce que l'économie dans ce
pays est une discipline qui
malheureusement n'a pas
l'audience qu'elle devrait avoir et et
et et et sans doute dépend-t-il de nous
dans toute notre diversité de faire en
sorte d'animer grâce aux expertises
auxquelles nous pouvons accéder le débat
économique de le faire partager parce
que beaucoup de choses très
concrètes beaucoup de choses de la vie
de tous les jours dépendent de
l'économie et dépendent de ces
notions qui sont apparemment si
intellectuelles et si complexes VO voilà
je je je n'irai pas plus loin mais mais
je crois que que que nous avons avec la
mise en place du Haut Conseil un sujet
tout à fait passionnant et qui est au
cœur de notre démocratie si nous voulons
que la démocratie est un sens
et il faut que nous sachions intégrer la
place la juste place des instances
d'expertise et que la décision politique
dans ce qu' là de fondamental prennent
appui sur ces avis sans que ces avis
soient envahissant et ne se substitue à
ce qui doit émaner du suffrage universel
c'est c'est c'est bien toute la
difficulté peut-être notre société
n'est-elle pas encore suffisamment mû
mais peut-être ne la faisons-nous pas
mûir suffisamment n'est-ce pas alors je
laisse ces questions ouvertes je crois
que nous pas au-delà je vous propose de
terminer en saluant madame Mathilde
Lemoine comme nous avons salué Michel
Aglietta mes chers collègues donc la
séance commune est levée n'est-ce pas
madame la Présidente voilà et nous
allons poursuivre nos Activ